cette commission nous avons des
collègues monsieur le ministre qui sont
aussi en PLFSS et visiblement il y a une
discussion sur la taxation des vins en
ce moment qui voilà
qui au Sénat ne permet pas de lutter
voilà par rien d'autre voilà et donc je
vous propose que nous commencions
donc dans le cadre de nos auditions
budgétaires que nous commençons
aujourd'hui nous attendons nous
entendons pardon aujourd'hui Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre délégué auprès du
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires chargés
de la ville et du logement qui vient
nous présenter le projet du budget de
son ministère pour 2023 je voudrais vous
souhaiter la la bienvenue je crois qu'on
n'a pas fait encore d'audition c'est
votre première audition donc bienvenue
dans notre commission et je précise à
chacun que cette audition est diffusée
en vidéo en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et sera disponible ensuite en
vidéo à la demande voilà pour les
affaires d'usage monsieur le ministre
vous nous présenter ce soir un budget en
progression nominale je dis progression
nominale que nous sommes nous sommes
rentrés dans une période d'inflation de
l'ordre de 4,2% pour l'année prochaine
et c'est à l'aulne de cette inflation
qui nous faut naturellement comprendre
l'évolution des budgets en volume qui
nous sont proposés dans une mission
cohésion des territoires qui s'accroît
globalement de
3,9%, les trois programmes dédiés au
logement suivent la même dynamique et
celui d'évolue à la ville augmente même
de 7,1% la Commission est
particulièrement attachée à ces sujets
et nous ne voulons pas cacher notre
satisfaction que des demandes légitimes
et pu être entendues je pense par
exemple au Quartier d'été mais dans un
budget général en déficit de 5% et une
dette qui dépasse 110% du PIB la
responsabilité collective mais celle du
Sénat en particulier est d'aller au-delà
de la facilité de considérer comme bon
un budget en augmentation le budget que
vous nous présentez aujourd'hui
ressemble fort à un budget de transition
en matière de financement du logement
social de rénovation des habitations et
de politique de la ville nous sommes en
attente de votre part non pas de
solution miracle car je pense que
quelqu'un les aurait trouvés depuis le
temps mais d'une stratégie de long terme
sur ce mandat d'une hiérarchisation des
objectifs et d'orientation plus réelle
en matière de financement du logement
social nous sommes entre la RLS qui est
prolongée encore une fois cette année et
le pacte de confiance qui j'espère
portera bien son nom mais au regard de
la construction du PLF 2023 je dois vous
dire que c'est plutôt l'inquiétude qui
domine sous couvert de négociation en
cours se fait ce fameux pacte de
confiance et sur la convention
quinquennale Action Logement a de
nouveau été mis à contribution contre sa
volonté j'oserais dire que c'est pour
Action Logement un peu l'histoire sans
fin une ponction dans ses comptes des
engagements de pacte de confiance de
part et d'autre et qui tombent dès la
construction du budget suivant
parallèlement la requalification par
l'INSEE en administration publique de sa
filiale Action Logement service qui
prélève je rappelle et distribue la
participation des employeurs à l'effort
de construction la tech laisse augurer à
nouveau impossible de membrement du
groupe et une budgétérisation
budgétérinaire budgétisation
pardonnez-moi de la paix vous nous
éclairez évidemment sur vos intentions
or sur ce sujet dans la lignée du
travail de nos collègues Valérie Letard
Dominique Estrosi Sassone et Viviane
Artigalas et Marie-Noël linman notre
commission à deux convictions très
fortes vous voyez qui traverse les
groupes politiques la première c'est
qu'il les philosophiquement essentiel
parce que c'est un héritage du pacte
social de l'après-guerre et que cela a
toujours du sens aujourd'hui que le
patronat et les syndicats soient
investis pour le logement des salariés
la seconde c'est qu'il est
budgétairement essentiel pour le
logement et la rénovation urbaine que
cet acteur reste autonome pour être
partenaire de longue durée nous sommes
convaincus que les bénéfices de court
terme des attaques contre Action
Logement sont en réalité des handicaps
de long terme pour le secteur au moment
où votre collègue de Bercy pourrait
demain prendre la décision de juridique
de classer l'as comme organisme
d'administration centrale avec de
nombreuses conséquences notamment
financières nous attendons du ministre
de la Ville et du Logement c'est-à-dire
de vous un engagement déterminé pour que
par-delà les nécessités d'un moment les
outils les acteurs et les financements
spécifiques du logement soient garanties
dans la durée ce budget est aussi un
budget de transition en matière de
rénovation des logements et nous revient
de mettre en oeuvre la loi climat
résilience et notamment les
interdictions de louer frappant les
logements EF et G or comme l'a montré
l'Institut Paris Région en Île-de-France
45% des résidences principales ont des
étiquettes énergétiques de cette nature
comment comptez-vous relever ce défi
technique ce défi financier alors que
l'énergie bien sûr pèse si lourd dans le
pouvoir d'achat des Français notre
commission avec notre rapporteur
Dominique Estrosi Sassone avait fait des
propositions pour desserrer le
calendrier des étiquettes e en
particulier et pour mieux accompagner
les propriétaires pour l'essentiel ces
propositions n'ont pas été retenues et
elles nous manque cruellement
aujourd'hui enfin c'est aussi un budget
de transition en matière du politique de
la ville l'année 2023 va être
déterminante pour le renouvellement des
contrats de ville la redéfinition de la
géographie prioritaire et l'aménagement
du cadre législatif et financier là
aussi notre commission a comme vous le
savez présenter des propositions
constructives en lien étroit avec les
maires concernées les rapporteurs sont
venus vous rendre leur rapport et en
s'appuyant sur votre travail à
l'Institut Montaigne pour aller de
l'avant et redonner une ambition claire
à cette politique être un tremplin pour
les habitants nous attendons donc que
vous présentiez vos intentions et votre
agenda pour les prochains mois et comme
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on est
reparti j'attire votre attention sur les
quartiers qui ont été déclassés de la
politique de la ville en 2014 qui sont
dans des communes qui sont commune
fragile socialement très souvent qui
sont souvent très proches d'autres
villes qui elles sont en politique de la
de la ville et qui ont subi si je
m'exprimer ainsi c'est pas le bon terme
les des effets collatéraux des
démolitions reconstruction et qui
aujourd'hui sont en situation très
dégradées et qui se dégradent alors que
les communes ont connu aussi une
raréfaction de l'argent public et de
leur propre capacité à agir on est
aujourd'hui dans des villes qui sont
extrêmement fragilisées et des quartiers
qui sont en train de tomber sur bien des
sujets monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse maintenant nous présenter votre
budget j'ai été trop longue pardonner
moi pour 2023 et répondre à ces
premières interpellations après quoi je
donnerai la parole aux rapporteur de la
commission c'est à dire Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne pour le logement
Viviane Artigalas pour la ville
Jean-Baptiste blanc qui rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances et
qui se trouve ici et peut-être qu'à l'un
Dufour qui est le rapporteur pour avis
de une émission des affaires sociales
nous rejoindra mais je n'en suis pas sûr
puis naturellement aux collègues qui
souhaiteront s'exprimer monsieur le
ministre c'est à vous voilà
mais merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames les sénatrices mais messieurs
les sénateurs je tiens à vous dire tout
d'abord l'honneur qui est le mien d'être
auditionné aujourd'hui ce soir par par
votre commission afin de vous présenter
les crédits du projet de loi de finances
pour 2023 mais comme vous m'y avait
invité ma feuille de route et me
projeter au-delà de de ce PLF 2023 en
tant que élu municipal depuis plus de 25
ans vous vous imaginez mon mon
attachement aux collectivités et la
politique du logement englobe de
nombreux sujets vous l'avez déjà rappelé
et la conjecture actuelle nous impose
d'agir d'agir vite d'agir fort et d'agir
de façon globale et cette politique du
logement ne doit bien sûr pas réaliser
les difficultés du secteur difficulté de
la demande avec l'enjeu de solvabilité
des ménages l'accès au crédit les
difficultés liées à l'offre alors qu'il
existe d'importants freins à la
construction je dirais malheureusement
ma mission celle du gouvernement et de
faire que je crois comme je le disais ce
matin dans la presse le logement ne soit
pas la bombe sociale de demain et pour
cela nous nous donnons en tout cas c'est
mon souhait les moyens de nos ambitions
en effet le budget en faveur du logement
pour 2023 prévoit premièrement
d'accompagner les Français tout au long
de leur parcours résidentiel et
deuxièmement d'accompagner les
territoires pour une politique du
logement avec la transition écologique
la politique que je souhaite aussi
mettre en oeuvre mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices c'est une
politique qui allie l'urbain et l'humain
lié la politique de la ville et du
logement comme ont décidé de le faire le
président de la République et la
première ministre permet d'avoir des
résultats forts dans nos quartiers et je
sais que vous le savez des quartiers
dans lesquels la participation citoyenne
est favorisée des quartiers dans
lesquels on permet l'émancipation et le
plein emploi
le quartier dans lesquels on mène une
politique exigeante contre les fractures
les vulnérabilités notamment écologiques
mais aussi contre les discriminations
pour que les habitants des quartiers se
sentent pleinement citoyens de la
République tous leurs devons l'accès aux
droits l'accès à des logements dignes
l'accès au service public et bien sûr
l'accès aux transports c'est donc une
politique que je souhaite mener et
construire avec les élus locaux
la première des priorités c'est
évidemment dans la contexte actuel celle
du pouvoir d'achat contre la hausse des
prix dans le contexte actuel d'inflation
le gouvernement a agi très rapidement
avec le paquet pouvoir d'achat voter en
juillet le logement vous le savez et le
premier poste des dépenses des ménages
et conformément aux engagements de la
première ministre nous devions agir
ainsi vous avez adopté un plafonnement
de la hausse des loyers à 3,5%. alors
que cette eau serait pu atteindre
jusqu'à 6% en 2023 une revalorisation
des aPL de 3 et demi pour cent ça
concerne 5,8 millions de foyers dont 2,6
millions de foyers en logements social
ces mesures représentent 300 millions
d'euros de dépenses et s'inscrivent dans
une démarche globale de ce gouvernement
pour maintenir le pouvoir d'achat de
tous les Français
le deuxième point
c'est le parcours résidentiel pour moi
être ministre du Logement c'est bien
être le ministre du parcours résidentiel
la question qui se pose c'est à chaque
étape de la vie quel logement
sommes-nous capables de proposer aux
habitants de ce pays pour la famille qui
s'agrandit et qui souhaite devenir
propriétaire de son logement nous
l'accompagnons avec la possibilité
d'obtenir un prêt à taux zéro ce
dispositif a permis de soutenir 75 000
ménages en 2021 et sa pertinence et bien
sûr renforcée par le contexte de taux
actuel le PLF 2023 le maintien inchangé
et nous devrons travailler ensuite à lui
donner à partir de 2024
pour la personne âgée qui souhaite
pouvoir rester chez elle dans un
logement adapté c'est bien sûr ma prime
manœuvre à laquelle vous le savez le
président de la République et la
première ministre sont très attachés
nous aiderons nos aînés à mieux vieillir
chez eux c'était comme je l'ai rappelé
une promesse de la campagne du président
de la République les crédits de la NAS
sont renforcés de 35 millions d'euros
dans le pls pour enclencher cette
dynamique d'aide 2023
ce parcours résidentiel il doit
évidemment concerner également ceux qui
n'ont pas de logement le mal logement le
sans-abrisme sont des fléaux contre
lesquels nous luttons tous les jours
avec des résultats le président de la
République avait initié dès 2017 la
politique du logement d'abord cinq ans
plus tard c'est près de 400 000
personnes qui ont pu accéder à un
logement et la production de logements
adaptés à doubler nous allons poursuivre
cet effort avec un nouveau plan logement
d'abord
je souhaite aussi que ce plan continue à
être exemplaire sur deux terrains de
sujets d'abord l'atterritorialisation
autour des SIAO et des élus aujourd'hui
45 territoires contribuent à accélérer
le logement d'abord et je souhaite me
nourrir de leurs idées ensuite la
performance et le suivi des résultats il
y avait eu un rapport du Sénat en 2018
sur l'hébergement d'urgence des
sénateurs harnelles et Mauricet 4 ans
après il est intéressant de constater
qu'une bonne part des efforts de
pilotage demandé ont été mis en œuvre
mais beaucoup restent à faire
le PLF 2023 reflète déjà les dynamiques
que je souhaite porter il a lou 44
millions d'euros supplémentaires à la
production de logements et à la
prévention des expulsions locatives face
aux besoins inédits en particulier de la
part de famille avec enfants il
maintient pour 2023 un très haut niveau
de place d'hébergement d'urgence
pour permettre ce parcours résidentiel
il est indispensable de travailler
étroitement ce qu'on essaye de faire ce
que l'on fait je crois avec l'ensemble
des acteurs du logement et les bailleurs
sociaux en particulier c'est l'idée vous
l'avez rappelé madame la Présidente du
pacte de confiance avec l'ensemble des
acteurs du logement social qui a annoncé
la première ministre et que je souhaite
construire rapidement pour qu'il donne
une vision de long terme à tous les
acteurs du logement social dès 2023 le
budget vient stabiliser le modèle de
financement du logement social en
soutenant la production de 110 000
logements sociaux en cette année 2023
soutenir la rénovation du parc social
avec une enveloppe dédiée la rénovation
thermique notamment du parc social avec
une enveloppe dédiée de 200 millions
d'euros pour arriver à ce niveau de
construction l'État doit pouvoir
s'appuyer sur les mers c'est vrai aussi
dans la dynamique du logement d'abord
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure ils ont
une obligation avec la loi SRU mais je
veux que nous nous allions au-delà de
cet aspect contraignant toujours dans le
dialogue et c'est l'idée aussi de ce
pacte de confiance la loi SRU a fait
l'objet de débat important l'an dernier
dans cette chambre lors de l'examen de
la loi 3DS je crois que l'équilibre
trouver est le bon vous avez pérennisé
la loi et ses exigences mais vous avez
aussi laissé largement sa place au
dialogue social je poursuivrai cet
exemple je veux un dialogue local
exigeant pour que la loi srue soit
respectée par toujours plus de communes
c'est le sens des contrats de mixité
sociale que je souhaite signer avec
toutes les communes volontaires
favoriser le parcours résidentiel cela
passe tout d'abord par améliorer les
logements existants nous avons pour cela
quatrevers le nouveau programme national
de renouvellement urbain il est
aujourd'hui pleinement déployé 450
projets sont validés des chantiers
engagés dans près de 400 quartiers et
les 12 milliards d'euros prévus seront
bientôt intégralement à louer bien
évidemment pas intégralement dépensé et
je le rappelle quand on décide de
dépenser en gros 12 milliards d'euros
pour les quartiers en renouvellement
urbain l'effort l'investissement sera
environ à la fin du programme de 50
milliards d'euros tout programmes et
toute action confondues collectivité
locale bailleur etc j'en profite pour
saluer à cette suite l'action de la rue
mais aussi de l'ensemble des maires et
des présidents d'intercommunalité des
quartiers en politique de la ville qui
s'engagent pleinement dans ces
opérations de reconstruction de
démolition de construction public
l'accélération encore de la Rénovation
Énergétique est une priorité du
gouvernement et je crois qu'il faut dire
il faut dire avec forte que les
résultats sont là ma prime rénove c'est
la réussite de la massification des
travaux de rénovation à virgule 5
millions de chantiers 1,5 millions de
projets ont été soutenus depuis 2020
dont plus de 160 000 rénovations
globales contrairement aux 2500 que vous
entendez souvent cité
2,1 milliard d'euros en 2021 qui ont
bénéficié à plus de 80% de ménage très
modestes et modestes quand ce n'était
qu'environ 10% avec le crédit d'impôt
dans la version antérieure un gars
énergétique moyen par logement également
en hausse de 30 % par rapport au cite en
intérieur
en un mot je le redis ma prime rénov ça
fonctionne c'est une réussite mais il
faut maintenant accélérer en effet on
reproche souvent au logement de
représenter 20% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et moi je crois que l'on
doit faire du logement l'avant-garde
éclairé si j'ose dire de la transition
écologique et nous en avons les moyens
dans le PLF 2023 il est prévu 2,45
milliards d'euros sur le dispositif
socle de ma prime rénov un renforcement
d'environ 130 millions d'euros des
autres aides de Lana en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique pour consolider
la dynamique inédite de la relance cette
accélération se traduisera par des
évolutions des aides pour plus de
rénovation performantes et globale et
une attention accrue doit être portée au
passoire thermique dont vous avez madame
la Présidente rappeler le calendrier
avec son ambition par un meilleur
accompagnement notamment des ménages
c'est l'enjeu du service public France
Renov vous devez entendre les petites
potes de publicité à la radio et à la
télévision il faut avoir donné aux
Français une information et un conseil
accessible sous cette bannière unique
France rénoble avec de la visibilité de
la structuration progressive d'un réseau
d'accompagnateurs ce qui est
indispensable que chacun puisse avoir
les bonnes informations auxquelles il a
droit et c'est le rôle des
accompagnateurs rénovent agréés qui se
déploieront tout au long de l'année 2023
pour atteindre un chiffre de
ces accompagnateurs rénov agréés seront
chargés d'amener les ménages vers des
projets les plus ambitieux et leur faire
connaître les aides auxquelles ils ont
droit enfin par la poursuite du soutien
au copropriété de tous types parce que
bien évidemment l'enjeu maintenant de la
rénovation énergétique c'est celle de
l'habitacle collectif et l'aide ma prime
rénov copropriété sera notamment
évidemment prolongé pour accentuer
l'effort de rénovation des logements en
collectif de sorte de diminuer les
restes à charge des travaux et aider à
la décision de prise de ces travaux en
assemblée générale
enfin nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
voir des gens vivre dans ces conditions
insupportables de passoire thermique
vous le savez depuis la fin du mois
d'août les loyers dépasseoirs
énergétiques F et G sont gelés les
prochaines échéances produits par la loi
climat et résilience vont ensuite
progressivement conduire à
l'interdiction de remise en location
dépasseoir énergétiques et il est
important que nous tenions ce calendrier
dans un esprit évidemment de ne pas
laisser les gens vivre dans les
passoires thermiques l'idée c'est de ne
pas remettre des gens à la rue bien sûr
et nous travaillerons avec l'ensemble
des acteurs mais il est important que
ceux qui vivent dans des passoires
thermiques ne puissent pas rester dans
ces conditions là sans que nous prenions
les dispositions alors qualité de vie
dans leur logement cet interdiction
s'appliquera à tous les logements et je
le rappelle nous y tenons y compris au
bien destiné à la location en meublé
touristique ou pire encore n'oubliez pas
un effet d'aubaine et de transformation
d'un certain nombre de logements qui ne
pourraient plus être conservés en
location mais transformer en le un logé
touristique et nous mettrons tous les
garde-fous nécessaires
le quatrième point c'est celui de
réconcilier la France avec l'acte de
construire pour que chacun puisse se
loger en fonction de ce parcours de vie
il faut construire plus de logements de
tous types là où sont bien sûr les
besoins les plus importants et la
première chose des choses sera de
reconstruire collectivement un discours
positif sur l'acte de construire avec
les mers et l'ensemble des acteurs
alors oui permettez-moi l'expression il
faut construire plus pour loger plus on
sait le faire en étant exemplaire
on sait le faire en étant exemple R et à
plus de 2 millions 200000 français qui
sont en recherche de logement donc on
peut pas penser que le besoin est
aujourd'hui couvert on peut le faire en
étant exemplaire en matière
environnementale la dynamique est en
cours et je le vois les promoteurs les
architectes les entreprises du bâtiment
et des travaux publics sont atteints de
transformer en profondeur leur activité
pour répondre à cette ambition
environnementale et à l'exigence de la
nouvelle réglementation environnementale
2020 la fameuse
erreur 2020 elle donne un cadre
réglementaire ambitieux en portant dans
la construction neuve plusieurs
objectifs se briété énergétique sortie
des énergies fossiles diminution de
l'impact carbone confort d'été etc
enfin nous accélérons dans la
construction de la ville durable la
première ministre a annoncé un fond vert
dorénavant doté de 2 milliards d'euros
pour les collectivités locales c'est un
engagement fort pour accélérer la
transition écologique de nos villes et
de nos territoires l'été 2022 nous a
encore démontré que l'exceptionnel va et
risque de devenir la norme et qu'il faut
agir ce fond va permettre d'accompagner
les collectivités dans leurs projets
pour adapter la ville au changement
climatique pour régénérer des friches
urbaines pour réaménager des surfaces
commerciales et des services devenus
obsolètes enfin pour rénover les
équipements et les bâtiments publics
c'est du concret et surtout c'est un
fond à destination des élus locaux qui
sont les mieux placés pour porter des
projets de transition écologique adaptés
à leur territoire
voilà madame la Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs les
grandes orientations de ma feuille de
route en tant que ministre délégué à la
ville et au logement j'ai plus parlé de
logements de ville mais je reviendrai
probablement sur la question de la ville
dans vos questions les sujets sont
nombreux les urgences aussi et je compte
mettre toute mon énergie pour relever
ses défis ces grands défis sur lesquels
j'aurai l'occasion d'échanger dès la fin
du mois de novembre à l'occasion du
Conseil national de la refondation le
CNR dédié au logement il sera un moment
important d'échanges et de réflexion
mais qui ne remplacent en rien
évidemment le travail parlementaire mais
qui permet de créer du consensus de
bâtir j'ai l'espère des solutions
partager et de remettre les citoyens au
cœur des grands choix de notre pays
et je suis évidemment maintenant à votre
disposition pour répondre aux questions
peut-être en commençant par les vôtres
madame Présidente je ne suis pas encore
un habitué de vos de vos organisations
vous voulez vous attacher
après aux autres questions qui vous
seront posez on va prendre les
rapporteurs et puis ensuite vous on fera
un petit break pour que vous puissiez
les leur répondre et à ce moment-là vous
ferez un tour global donc je vais donner
la parole à Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
que vous ne connaissez pas merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre alors
je voudrais vous interroger tout d'abord
sur le budget qui est dévolue dans ce
projet de loi de finances à
l'hébergement d'urgence et à l'accès au
logement car donner un toit à chacun
vous l'avez rappelé et bien évidemment
la première des exigences les moyens du
programme 177 sont importants et
globalement l'État est au rendez-vous
financier via des PLF croissants et des
ajustements en cours d'année cependant
le secteur a besoin de stabilité de
lisibilité et d'avoir les moyens
d'assurer l'accompagnement social qui
vous le savez et la clé de la réussite
de la politique du logement d'abord tout
récemment parce qu'il y avait quand même
un certain nombre d'associations qui
grondaient par rapport à la diminution
des crédits sur les bergement d'urgence
vous avez annoncé 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour maintenir un parc
de
197.000 places ont renonçant ainsi au
baisse programmées initialement pour
autant beaucoup estiment une telle
enveloppe encore insuffisante au regard
des coûts
prévoyez-vous d'aller plus loin en
termes d'accompagnement et ici dans
cette commission à plusieurs reprises on
a souvent et je pense à juste titre mis
l'accent sur la nécessaire la nécessité
de l'accompagnement social que ce soit
pour le logement d'abord ou pour la
structuration du service public de la
rue au logement il me remonte de plus en
plus de la part des associations de
graves difficultés de recrutement et un
réel problème d'attractivité des métiers
je suis par exemple interpellé sur le
fait que les écoutant des SIAO ne
bénéficient pas des revalorisations qui
ont été obtenus par d'autres catégories
de travailleurs sociaux
vous apporter une réponse à cette
injustice je voudrais également attirer
votre attention sur la situation qui
peut être dans certains cas très
difficile compte tenu de la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie de certains
gestionnaires de logement foyer ou de
logement accompagné en effet lorsque la
facturation aux résidents est
forfaitaire le gestionnaire doit
supporter l'essentiel de la hausse sans
pouvoir la répercuter alors que les
hébergers bénéficient du chèque énergie
Adoma et l’unafo ont présenté plusieurs
pistes de solutions comme l'attribution
du chèque énergie au gestionnaire une
modification des conditions de révision
des forfaits ou encore de refacturer
partiellement les consommations
excessives comme cela se fait déjà pour
l'eau que comptez-vous faire à sujet en
matière de rénovation et de construction
neuve on entend de plus en plus une
petite musique qui n'est pas celle que
je partage ou certains commencent à dire
qu'il faudrait finalement choisir entre
les deux entre la rénovation et la
construction neuve c'est bien un domaine
où le en même temps que je ne privilégie
en aucun cas aurait pourtant tout son
sens parce que je pense effectivement et
vous l'avez signalé monsieur le ministre
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui une
crise du logement qui est
particulièrement grave et qui je pense
ne va cesser de s'aggraver tout au long
des mois à venir en tout cas pour
l'année 2023 et s'il fallait à un moment
donné faire des choix entre d'un côté la
rénovation et de l'autre côté la
construction neuve ce serait revenir sur
les conclusions de la commission
repsamen à laquelle j'ai pu participer
et qui avait pu aboutir à un consensus
sur le besoin en construction neuve ce
serait également particulièrement
dangereux au regard des besoins
urgents d'accès au logement que vous
avez répertorié dans le cadre de votre
discours les bailleurs sociaux mais
aussi les promoteurs sont très
préoccupés par l'accès aux fonciers
certains opérateurs s'inquiètent que le
nouveau fond vert conserve tous les
avantages et la simplicité du fond
friche qui s'est révélée être une mesure
efficace pour débloquer des dossiers
complexes pourriez-vous nous rassurer
sur ce point en matière de rénovation je
suis préoccupé par un discours qui n'est
pas nouveau uniquement punitif vis-à-vis
des propriétaires qui sont bien loin
d'être tous des marchands de sommeil
louant des logements indignes faisant
attention au terme beaucoup sont
confrontés aux difficultés techniques et
financières de la rénovation et pourrait
bien retirer leur bien du marché alors
j'ai dit avec plaisir dans votre
entretien du Parisien Aujourd'hui que
vous parliez du statut du bailleur privé
et bien sachez que vous trouverez ici au
Sénat en tout cas dans cette commission
une écoute plus qu'attentive parce que
ça fait de nombreuses années que je
plaise dans mes interventions la
nécessité de mettre en place un
véritable statut du bailleur privé je
crois qu'il faut effectivement les aider
les bailleurs privés plutôt que de
continuer à prendre des mesures
coercitives à leur rencontre je reste
convaincu qu'un geste comme
l'actualisation du déficit foncier sur
l'inflation serait un signal efficace
dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résidence j'étais même allé beaucoup
plus loin puisque j'avais proposé un
certain nombre de mesures fiscales et
financières à destination des
propriétaires sachant que elle ne serait
pas retenue dans la loi climat et
résilience j'avais l'époque même proposé
un doublement du déficit foncier à
quelques mois véritablement je pense que
l'actualisation du déficit foncier sur
l'inflation serait véritablement un
signal important pour que les
propriétaires véritablement soient
embarqués dans cette dans cette volonté
de rénovation énergétique de leur
logement et surtout pour éviter que bon
nombre de ses logements ne sortent du
marché locatif ma prime rénove copro est
également une bonne mesure qui prend
progressivement je dis bien
progressivement de l'ampleur on pourrait
accélérer et débloquer certains dossiers
en permettant à l'ANA là aussi de
doubler la prime pour les propriétaires
modestes de même sans doute faut-il
bouger les curseurs pour que le soutien
à la rénovation globale soit toujours
plus avantageux que celui au geste
unique de travaux pensez-vous pouvoir
agir en ce sens
et puis vous avez parlé du parc social
les enjeux ne sont pas moins forts bien
évidemment les bailleurs ont moins de
marge de manœuvre avec la RLS avec la
hausse des taux d'intérêt avec la hausse
du taux du livret A qui pourrait peser
demain encore plus fortement sur leur
capacité d'autofinancement l'USH a fait
des propositions pour aller directement
vers les meilleures étiquettes
énergétiques dans l'objectif de la
stratégie nationale bas carbone et
financer ce que l'on appelle ce que l'on
entend dire maintenant sur la deuxième
vie des logements qu'en pensez-vous donc
ça c'était sur la partie budget donc on
a bien compris monsieur le ministre que
ce budget est un budget transition nous
ce que nous souhaiterions c'est
véritablement que pour les quatre années
qui vont venir que nous puissions avoir
de la lisibilité lisibilité sur le
budget du logement le logement ça
s'inscrit dans le temps long et jusqu'à
présent malheureusement nous avons
déplorer une politique du stop and go
une politique sans aucune lisibilité
visibilité qui fasse que les opérateurs
quels qu'ils soient privés comme public
ne savent pas très bien où aller et
d'une année sur l'autre et bien sont
quelque part contraints dans leur
capacités à agir alors si vous pouviez
dans la période dans laquelle nous
allons passer à partir de 2023 nous
donner quelques assurances sur une
lisibilité quand à une politique du
logement nous en serions
particulièrement heureux et satisfait
nous ici bien sûr au Parlement mais je
pense surtout avant tout aux acteurs qui
interviennent dans le champ du logement
et puis deux dernières questions qui
sont peut-être hors budget mais vous
l'avez évoqué comment pensez-vous
matérialiser votre annonce sur
l'interdiction des passoires thermiques
sur les meublés de tourisme est-ce qu'il
va y avoir un véhicule législatif
Haddock qui va concerner cette mesure
entre autres et puis un dernier point
madame la Première ministre a annoncé
l'extension du bouclier tarifaire sur de
gaz au ménage résident en copropriété et
en logements social en chauffage
collectif quels vont être les modalités
de mise en oeuvre de ce bouclier je vous
ai interpellé directement par courrier
parce que vous le savez il y a un
certain nombre de copropriétés qui sont
en chauffage collectif au gaz et j'en ai
moi-même dans la ville de Nice je suis
allé les rencontrer qui ont pris
aujourd'hui la décision de ne pas se
chauffer parce que les charges sont
beaucoup trop importantes et que le
bouclier tarifaire auquel ils peuvent
avoir droit ils sont obligés de faire
les avances de charge et ils n'arrivent
pas à pouvoir faire ses avances de
charge au regard du bouclier tarifaire
qui en plus est perçu beaucoup trop
tardivement eux ce que souhaite ses
copropriétés qui sont en chauffage
collectif au gaz c'est de pouvoir avoir
le même bouclier tarifaire que les
copropriétés qui sont actuellement en
chauffage individuel au gaz merci
merci Dominique certains collègues nous
font remarquer qu'on peut faire ça
peut-être à Nice mais moins dans sa voix
c'est un peu plus compliqué voilà merci
Dominique la parole est à Viviane
Artigalas merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
interroger pour ma part sur le volet
politique de la ville vous êtes bien
placé pour savoir en tant qu' ancien
président de la rue que l'agence a
retrouvé toute sa dynamique et que nous
sommes maintenant entrés dans la phase
active du NPN ru avec de plus en plus de
chantier et de besoin de paiement dans
ce contexte je suis très préoccupée de
voir que l'État n'apportera que 15
millions d'euros au programme de l'année
prochaine au cours des cinq dernières
années il n'a financé que la moitié
environ des 200 millions d'euros promis
quand sera-t-il à l'avenir alors que
l'État doit encore 1,1 milliard d'euros
d'ici 2031 et qu'il devrait verser de
l'ordre de 110 millions d'euros par an
sur 10 ans pouvez-vous prendre
l'engagement donc l'État sera bien au
rendez-vous et assumera sa part de
financement de la rénovation urbaine
vous prédécesseurs ont indiqué relancé
le recrutement d'adultes relais pour
appuyer les associations et développer
la médiation sociale dans les quartiers
le chiffre officiel est de 6514 adultes
relais la réalité des effectifs sur le
terrain et de l'ordre de 4600 soit pas
tellement plus qu'au début du
quinquennat précédent comment expliquer
cet échec et comment comptez-vous y
remédier certains évoquent le niveau de
rémunération et les problèmes de
professionnalisation qui expliquerait la
faible attractivité des postes est-ce
exact je voudrais aborder ensuite la
question de l'évaluation et plus
particulièrement la situation de
l'Observatoire national de la politique
de la ville Lowen PV l'évaluation
dynamique de la politique de la ville
est une question centrale pour mesurer
ses effets sur les habitants nous avons
plaidé dans notre transport pour
beaucoup plus d'études de cohort mais
nous avons constaté que le NPV dépourvu
du président depuis près d'un an
disposant de toujours moins de
personnels et de liens avec la recherche
et devenue une coquille vide cela paraît
peut-être un subjugé technocratique mais
c'est une réalité très importante c'est
en réalité très importante on ne peut
pas par exemple qu'on se voit de
dépenser 40 milliards d'euros dans le
npru sans évaluation comment répondre
aux critiques de la Cour des comptes et
comment comprendre ce qui se joue dans
ces quartiers sans évaluation je
voudrais donc savoir ce que vous comptez
faire pour relancer le NPV et relever ce
défi de l'évaluation et de la recherche
sur la politique de la ville enfin les
villes abritent des villes abritant des
qpv sont aujourd'hui particulièrement
touchés par l'inflation et la hausse des
coût de l'énergie car elles sont plus
pauvres que les autres qu'est-il prévu
pour les accompagner et les aider à
passer le cap
le gouvernement acceptait un coup de
pouce complémentaire de 110 millions
d'euros pour la DSR à l'Assemblée
nationale étant élu d'un département
rural je m'en réjouis et je demande que
non garde ce dispositif mais un geste
équivalent sur la DSU est-il envisagé au
Sénat ce n'est pas moins attendu et
légitime voilà pour le budget et ensuite
je voudrais revenir sur une des
questions de de Sophie prima est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire hors budgétaire
avoir quelles sont vos intentions et
votre agenda pour les premiers prochains
mois sur les contrats de ville
merci Viviane et nous allons terminer
ces premières
interventions par Jean-Baptiste blanc
qui est le rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances Jean-Baptiste
ex-commissaire de la commission des
affaires économiques qu'on a toujours
plaisir à retrouver avec toujours la
même nostalgie
donc monsieur le ministre et chers
collègues je vous remercie
pour cette invitation devant la
commission et d'avoir organisé cette
audition de y avoir convié car c'est peu
de dire monsieur le ministre que vous
êtes attendu sur beaucoup de sujets on
le comprend tous la cohésion des
interventions merci de nous avoir fait
part de vos objectifs concernant la
politique du logement car jusqu'à
présent on avait assez peu d'éléments en
tout cas me concernant s'agissant par
exemple de l'hébergement le PLF a été
présenté avec un objectif d'abaisser le
parc d'hébergement d'urgence à 186000
places fin 2023 soit une baisse
d'environ 14000 places mais vous avez
récemment confirmé ce qu'on présentait
et ce que je présentais après avoir
auditionné la dial en fait le nombre de
places va rester au nombre très élevé
atteint pendant la crise sanitaire
puisque le gouvernement a retenu une
ouverture de crédit supplémentaire de 40
millions ma collègue Dominique ça sonne
la rappeler dans le texte du PLF adopté
au moyen de 49-3 pouvez-vous expliquer
comment il est impossible de descendre
de le château alors que les restrictions
sanitaires n'ont plus courtes comment se
fait-il que la politique du logement
d'abord qui était censé favoriser le
passage direct des sans-abris vers le
logement n'empêche pas un nombre
toujours plus important d'entre eux de
s'arrêter à la case hébergement
j'aimerais aussi vous poser une question
simple quel est le nombre de personnes
sans abri en France une audition encore
cet après-midi de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre laisse apparaître 2000 enfants
dorment chaque soir dehors 7000 adultes
semble-t-il je sais que vous n'avez pas
la réponse car la dernière enquête de
l'INSEE sur le sujet remonte à 10 années
quand une nouvelle étude vous permettra
telle de fonder réellement cette
politique sur une connaissance réelle de
la population concernée avez-vous une
idée du nombre de personnes qui ne
devraient pas relever de votre ministère
mais de celui de l'Intérieur au titre de
la politique d'accueil des migrants et
des réfugiés aussi
au sujet j'ai reçu le responsable
d'Action Logement la semaine dernière
j'étais surpris d'apprendre que les
négociations de la nouvelle convention
quinquennale n'avait pas encore commencé
sera-t-il vraiment possible de les
conclure de la conclure de conclure
cette négociations d'ici la fin de
l'année au risque de causer des
difficultés en début d'année prochaine
et compte tenues de l'interdiction
d'emprunt sur une durée supérieure à un
an dont Action Logement service devrait
bientôt faire l'objet avez-vous un plan
B si l'organisme ne peut plus contribuer
autant qu'il le fait déjà au NP NRU aux
aides à la pierre au Fna VDL à action
cœur de ville et à tant d'autres
politiques publiques et quant à la
politique de la ville que vous
connaissez mieux que personne je
m'interroge sur le un sujet en
particulier celui de l'abattement de
taxes foncières sur les propriétés
bâties dont bénéficient des bailleurs
sociaux qui en échange doivent réaliser
des travaux d'amélioration dans les
quartiers en rue avez-vous un bilan de
l'utilisation de cet abattement j'ai été
saisi de très nombreux cas très nombreux
mères qui remarque que cette abattement
n'aurait pas apparemment apporter toutes
les contreparties prévues
par la loi enfin vous êtes bien sûr
attendu sur un sujet qui nous préoccupe
tous et certains d'entre nous plus
particulièrement dans la mission
conjointe de contrôle sur le 0
artificielisation net qui me hante
depuis un an je regrettais
au mois de juin l'absence de définition
d'un modèle de financement du zan et
rien ou presque ne figure à ce sujet
dans le projet de loi de finances votre
collègue crise au Béchu a évoqué une
forme de fiscalité qui renchérit le coût
de l'artificialisation en fournissant
des moyens collectivités devant la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du Sénat la semaine dernière
avez-vous une réflexion sur cette
question une position sur le sujet des
choses à nous dire c'est vraiment un
sujet qui met en ébullition tous les
territoires alors nous allons rendre
notre copie pour notre part à la fin du
mois de novembre mais évidemment je
ferai très curieux de d'avoir votre
position dès cette fin d'après-midi je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre merci
Jean-Baptiste monsieur le ministre je
vous laisse répondre à ces nombreuses
interrogations déjà qui couvrent un
champ large
merci Madame Présidente je vais essayer
de ne rien oublier et si j'oublie
vous me rappellerez vous me rappellerez
à l'ordre en commençant peut-être par
vos questions madame la Présidente et
question qui regroupe d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de questions déjà déjà
reprises par
les autres intervenants Action Logement
alors d'abord
très honnêtement tous les échanges que
j'ai depuis de nombreux mois avec Action
Logement
sont au cœur de la réflexion sur ce que
sera la nouvelle convention quinquennale
donc je ne peux pas penser que que
Action Logement ni son président ni sa
directrice générale pense que le sujet
de la nouvelle convention quinquennale
n'est pas d'ores et déjà sur la table
depuis je crois que je les ai reçus le 6
juillet en étant devenu ministre le 4 et
contenu de mes précédentes fonctions de
président de la rue
cette question ces échanges ont été
nombreux et pour ce qui est et je vais
continuer sur la suite du sujet personne
ignore les prises de position que
j'avais prises à l'époque comme
président de la rue pour dire à quel
point je pensais que le rôle d'Action
Logement était un rôle déterminant dans
un certain nombre de politiques celle du
renouvellement
urbain bien sûr celle d'action cœur de
ville celle d'un partenaire essentiel du
logement social donc je le dis je à ce à
ce stade malgré les évolutions malgré le
classement en administration publique
d'Action Logement je continue à penser
que la structure actuelle est la
meilleure structure pour continuer à
faire vivre le monde du logement social
néanmoins il est important et c'est
l'objet de la du travail que l'on doit
mener ensemble sur la la prochaine
convention quinquennale de bien défin
les responsabilités des uns et des
autres sur la production sur la
réhabilitation et effectivement il y a
eu un débat qui est toujours ouvert sur
le Fnac et donc l'aide à la pierre et se
prélèvement qui est le maintien du
prélèvement tel qu'il a existé suite aux
échanges sur le plan d'investissement
volontaire de trois fois 300 millions
d'euros et cette fois c'est une
quatrième fois 300 millions d'euros je
ne sais pas où je ne savais pas
d'une certaine manière comment on aurait
pu faire autrement dans la préparation
de ce PLF dans la mesure où si c'est pas
un prélèvement une contribution d'Action
Logement c'était la proposition d'Action
Logement c'était de faire que ce soit
les bailleurs eux-mêmes qui contribuent
à l'aide à la pierre donc où l'État bien
sûr madame la sénatrice mais mais en
l'état si vous dire l'État
continue à penser qu'il est important de
participer à la rénovation thermique et
bien évidemment ce sujet est sur la
table dans le cadre 1 du pacte de
confiance que nous construisons avec les
bailleurs sociaux et de la convention
quinquennale il n'y a pas de il y a pas
de silo en l'occurrence les deux débats
sont liés l'écriture de ce pacte de
confiance avec le monde HLM l'écriture
de la convention quinquennale sont des
sujets qui doivent être portés de
manière quasi simultanée
entre nous dans le cadre
un peu nouveau puisque lorsqu'il y a eu
les premières volontés ou idées de
budgéter la paix qu'on était pas dans un
classement en administration publique
donc il y a il y a forcément un contexte
qui a changé la dette la dette d'Action
Logement devient si j'ose dire une dette
maastrichienne et donc nous avons
collectivement la responsabilité et donc
sur le logiciel il faut qu'on travaille
tous ensemble mais je le redis le le
débat le débat et les échanges on
recevra avec Christophe vichu je crois
le 14 novembre
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
d'Action Logement pour marquer alors
peut-être de manière officielle le
lancement de la négociation du futur de
la future convention quinquennale mais
je peux vous assurer que que depuis
maintenant plus de trois mois nous y
travaillons et il est important de de
que chacun se mobilise à la fois ça a
été dit par Madame esprit ça sonne sur
la production neuve et et
la réhabilitation et il y a pas
d'opposition entre les deux bien au
contraire c'est c'est les deux chantiers
qu'il faut mener avec autant d'acuités
même si on le sait tous 80%
des logements dans lequel nous nous et
nos enfants habiterons en 2050 sont déjà
là donc la question de la réhabilitation
et de la rénovation est une question
extrêmement importante puisque elle
touche une partie majoritaire des
logements déjà présents sur le
territoire national
alors je vais comme si vous le permettez
je répondrai tout à l'heure à la
question de la cartographie de la
politique de la ville en même temps que
je répondrai à Madame Artigas
par contre vous avez posé une question
sur le la rénovation et énergétique et
le calendrier moi je crois à cet
objectif et cette aussi une question de
Madame exposition je crois à l'objectif
de tenir les les échéances pas dans une
logique culpabilitérice d'ailleurs je le
rappelle les propriétaires occupants
sont aussi bien aidés que les
propriétaires bailleurs ou à l'inverse
les propriétaires bailleurs sont aussi
bien aidés par ma prime rénov que les
propriétaires bailleurs donc il faut
que l'ensemble des aides soient connu
pour le logement individuel et
qu'effectivement on dépasse la
massification par une rénovation plus
performante voire là où c'est possible
une rénovation globale mais je veux pas
en étant un peu trivial jeter le bébé
avec l'eau d'humain ce qui a été fait
sur les 1,5 chantiers précédents sur un
certain nombre de gestes rien n'est
gâché c'est gestes sont utiles sont
utiles au portefeuille de ce qui
habitent dans les logements et sont
utiles à la planète et puis s'ils
doivent recommencer d'autres chantiers
ils partiront pas de zéro si on a changé
son ballon en ballon thermodynamique
c'est déjà une bonne chose de fait si on
a fait juste unitée c'est déjà une bonne
chose de fait si on a fait que de
changer ses fenêtres c'est déjà une
bonne chose de faite et on partira parce
que de toute façon une rénovation
performante ou globale n'est qu'une
somme de geste mais ce qui est important
c'est que avec les conseillers France
Renov et les accompagnateurs agréer on
puisse lancer tous ces chantiers en
toute connaissance de cause et c'est
vrai que moi je pense qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'éclairer chaque porteur de
projet individuel ou collectif et c'est
ça l'enjeu qui est notre aujourd'hui
c'est renforcer notre effort sur le
logement collectif et en particulier les
copropriété dégradées qui concernent
bien évidemment la part la plus
importante du parc et en particulier du
parc locatif et là où vous avez raison
il va falloir qu'on soit très attentif
c'est qu'un copropriétaire bailleur ou
habitants qui habitent un appartement en
F ou en G
risque de se trouver en difficulté pour
changer d'étiquette si un certain nombre
des problématiques qui sont les siennes
sont liées aussi à la structure du bâti
et donc là il faudra le moment venu voir
comment
l'accompagnement que l'on fera auprès
des copropriétés puis cette
suffisamment efficace pour que au moins
les travaux nécessaires et pu être voté
par par l'assemblée générale après on
étudiera les cas mais je ne souhaite pas
faire à ce stade d'exception possible la
nouvelle règle qui permettrait de se
dire finalement on a du temps
aujourd'hui les gens qui habitent dans
les passoires thermiques n'ont pas de
temps on le voit tous un recrudescence
de bronchiolite de l'humidité enfin pour
avoir visité sans culpabiliser personne
un certain nombre de ces passwords
thermiques les logements la qualité du
logement sont indignes et donc on va on
va travailler on travaille on travaille
à la formation des artisans on travaille
à la qualification des diagnostiqueurs
pour que cette dynamique puisse être
présente et on travaille avec Lana et
l'ensemble de ses partenaires à monter
en charge à trouver les nouvelles aides
supplémentaires pour que ma prime rénov
notamment copropriété soit la plus
efficace possible
je vais prendre les questions de Madame
ça sonne dans l'ordre la première portée
sur l'hébergement d'urgence
effectivement la loi
prévoyait au départ une baisse de
l'émergement d'urgence puis ça a été
repris aussi par Me monsieur blanc
d'environ 7000 places en 2023 qui venait
suivre une première baisse en 2022 la
réalité c'est que
la réalité si j'ose dire nous rattrape
la présence et le besoin de place
d'hébergement d'urgence même à la sortie
du covid reste extrêmement importante ça
ne veut pas dire que le plan logement
d'abord est un échec parce que la
réalité c'est que le plan logement
d'abord a permis de faire sortir plus de
4 environ 390 000 à 400 000 personnes de
la rue au logement mais il reste compte
tenu
des conditions
politiques géopolitique de beaucoup de
personnes en grande difficulté qui ont
besoin de l'hébergement d'urgence et
donc la décision a été prise
par le gouvernement et la première
ministre de rajouter ces 400 millions
d'euros c'est 40 millions d'euros pardon
c'était trop pour maintenir à environ
197 198000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence pour que il n'y ait pas de
remise à la pas un retour de la gestion
de l'hébergement d'urgence au
thermomètre comme on a pu le connaître
le programme logement d'abord va être
relancé avec une vraie volonté mais là
encore le gouvernement ne peut pas faire
seul je sais ici que vous avez des
relations fortes avec les collectivités
locales et territoriales il faut comme
il faut convaincre de l'acte de
construire il faut convaincre les élus
et les habitants que avoir une pension
de famille avoir une résidence sociale à
côté de chez soi c'est loin d'être un
drame au contraire
ce sont de bons outils de bons outils
pour
quitter la rue et aller dans un parcours
résidentiel normal et donc on aura
besoin si on veut réussir le deuxième
plan d'abord que le regard sur sur ces
lieux d'accueil ce logement se toit et
évolue et échange mais j'en profite pour
répondre en même temps aux questions de
Monsieur
oui vous avez raison il est très
difficile aujourd'hui d'avoir des
chiffres extrêmement précis et du nombre
de sans-abris néanmoins on a décidé
parce que je vois très régulièrement
l'ensemble des associations en présence
du dial on travaille beaucoup et de la
DHP sur une proposition de l'association
Aurore de mettre en place un
observatoire qui va nous aider à avoir
une vision dynamique de la situation
avec les acteurs et l'ensemble des
associations sont des acteurs et
souhaite la mise en place de cette
observatoire et j'ai demandé à la dial
et à la DHP de mettre en place cette
observatoire ces questions aussi étaient
évoquées très récemment lors d'un
conseil de défense
sous la présidence du Président de la
République pour regarder on le sait
enfin c'est pas travailler un secret sur
les 200 000 personnes aujourd'hui en
hébergement d'urgence
la moitié environ
ne sont pas
en capacité d'accéder à un logement
puisque dans une situation
irrégulière ou quasiment
irrégulière et donc il demande du temps
parce que la réalité de l'hébergement
d'urgence c'est pas simplement ouvrir
une chambre d'hôtel si on veut un
hébergement d'urgence réussi il faut que
l'accompagnement social des familles
soit aussi présent et pour revenir à la
très bonne question mais elles étaient
toutes bonnes de Madame Estrosi saunson
sur les écoutants vous avez raison c'est
un travail extrêmement difficile j'ai
été rencontré et passé une soirée avec
eux avec mon collègue combe c'est c'est
quelque chose de d'extrêmement difficile
parfois de frustrant il gère ça avec des
tableaux Weleda et un moment
tard dans la nuit ils ont vraiment plus
de place à proposer et on peut on peut
on peut comprendre la difficulté la
première ministre nous a demandé de
travailler sur une prime exceptionnelle
pour pour les que les écoutants du SIAO
nous y travaillons et nous leur ferons
une proposition dans les jours où les
semaines qui viennent mais de même
manière très rapide pour l'instant il
est question d'une prime mais lors de la
réunion avec les acteurs de la grande
précarité la première ministre à redit
cette demande qu'elle m'avait faite et
qui il fallait aussi regarder de manière
plus structurelle comment on pouvait
accompagner ces personnes extrêmement
fragilisées
sur les résidences sociales oui on a vu
le point puisque le bouclier tarifaire
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui ne
s'applique pas et nous échangeons
je crois que c'est ce matin où hier je
sais plus je suis un peu perdu mais j'en
parlais à oui avec le président
pour Adoma ce matin c'est ce matin c'est
un point que nous avons effectivement
dans dans les radars sur lequel nous
travaillons pour trouver une aide
exceptionnelle et vous avez raison aussi
cette capacité d'utiliser le chèque
énergie non pas directement vers le
fournisseur une question qui dépasse
d'abord cette ce public là puisque ça
pourrait aussi être
utile à l'intérieur de d'une copropriété
où on ne peut pas non plus utiliser le
chèque énergie pour l'envoyer à son
syndic aujourd'hui et donc c'est c'est
des choses que on on regarde tout en
faisant attention que le chèque énergie
c'est ne peut pas enfin il faut il faut
éviter d'éventuelles dérives sur sur son
utilisation ou sa mauvaise utilisation
mais en tout cas on essaye et je crois
qu'on trouvera
la solution
[Musique]
la question la question du
bon donc je les ai déjà répondu mais
évidemment il y a pas de choix entre
rénovation et construction neuve
l'ambition qui est la nôtre c'est de
d'essayer d'être comme ça va être appelé
par la présidente
dans la production neuve de logements
social environ 110000 et une rénovation
annuelle d'environ 120 à 140 000
logements c'est c'est cet objectif qu'on
se donne dans le dans l'habitat social
et une ambition très grande dans
l'habitat dans l'habitat privé
le statut du bailleur privé vous en avez
parlé donc oui on y travaille je crois
effectivement moi je suis pas du tout
dans une logique culpabilisatrice
dans le parcours résidentiel on a besoin
d'avoir tout type de logement du
logement en accession bien sûr mais
aussi du logement en location dans le
patrimoine social et c'est normal mais
aussi
dans dans des copros privés et il
contribue à faire que que nos
concitoyens trouvent un logement et il
est important que que c'est
investisseurs
petits surtout enfin en tout cas c'est
ce que je souhaite aider soit protégés
et un statut soit aider dans les
rénovations thermiques et permettent à
concourir au parcours résidentiel donc
toujours pareil il y a des contreparties
un plafonnement des loyers il faut qu'on
prenne exemple sur sur locavage par
exemple qui est un dispositif qui qui
marche qu'on continue à développer la
protection des propriétaires à travers
visa et là aussi ça fait partie de notre
partenariat avec Action Logement et et
Action Logement est un partenaire
essentiel de visale donc c'est tout ça
sur lequel on va travailler dans les
mois qui viennent et je ne doute pas que
ça sera un des sujets qui reviendra lors
du CNR sur le fond vert je ne me
rappelle plus qui a été la question j'ai
juste noté fond vert
ah pardon excusez-moi
alors moi moi ce que j'ai compris
du fond vert c'est que oui l'idée de la
première ministre c'est de que ce fond
vert soit
à la main des préfets et puisse être
partagé la manière la plus efficace
possible tant sur la renaturation les
friches les équipements publics
dans nos villes les bâtiments et les
équipements publics l'objectif étant
d'adapter la ville au réchauffement
climatique et se font qui est
extrêmement important est un engagement
fort de la de la première ministre pour
accélérer la transition écologique de
nos villes et
je ne doute pas que les dispositifs de
redistribution de ce fond vert seront
les plus efficaces et les et les plus
faciles possibles le font free je vous
avais raison de de le rappeler c'est
1400 projets qui avaient pu être gagner
donc c'est vraiment un résultat
extrêmement
encourageant et et je souhaite qu'on
puisse continuer à travailler avec la
même avec la même dynamique
il y avait une question sur sur le
déficit foncier
[Musique]
alors là je je
vous avais raison je pense que c'est un
une discussion qu'il faudra qu'on ait
dans le cadre du PLF maintenant pour
voir la manière dont on pourrait en tout
cas c'est un dispositif qui qui marche
bien pour les propriétaires bailleurs
donc ça vaut le coup dans le cadre de
nos réflexions de de continuer à aller
travailler néanmoins je il y a d'autres
aides qui sont disponibles aussi j'en ai
pas parlé je crois tout à l'heure mais
mais les cope-tz et tunnel extrêmement
importante je rencontrais ce matin la
Caisse d'épargne
qui était extrêmement volontariste pour
mettre en oeuvre les coptz et et
notamment la Caisse d'Epargne
Île-de-France donc je pense que c'est
c'est un sujet qu'il faut qu'il faut
continuer et
et et vérifier
[Musique]
tous ces dispositifs d'aide
non de sens que s'il contribue à la
rénovation énergétique et sont des
leviers à la rénovation énergétique donc
à chaque fois que on pourra estimer que
que c'est un vrai effet de levier je
pense que vous avez raison il faut
utiliser les dispositifs qui marchent et
celui du déficit foncier peut en être un
ma prime rénove bon j'en ai déjà
beaucoup parlé mais
vous avez raison
je crois vraiment que ma prime manœuvre
aujourd'hui doit rentrer dans sa
continuer sa dynamique sur l'habitat
individuel c'est vraiment la première
étape dans la dans l'habitat individuel
améliorer l'accompagnement et aller le
plus possible vers des rénovations
globales performantes et globale et et
ensuite
continuer à à la développer en direction
de l'habitat collectif c'est vraiment un
enjeu on a passé plusieurs heures cette
semaine à travailler notamment avec Lana
pour voir comment on allait encore mieux
accompagner les copropriétés et les
copropriétaires il y a un sujet moi je
crois beaucoup à l'accompagnement des
copropriétés qui ensuite répartiront
auprès de leur copropriétaires le reste
à charge l'accompagnement aux
copropriétaires et parfois plus plus
difficile à cibler et à développer mais
en tout cas on
y travaille sur d'arrache-pied et bien
évidemment je ne doute pas que le
conseil d'administration de Lana qui se
tiendra dans les jours qui viennent
voilà même attention que nous sur sur la
manière dont on aidera au maximum les
propriétaires et en particulier les
propriétaires comme vous le rappelez les
plus modestes puisque à un moment dans
le vote en copropriété c'est le reste à
charge mais comme je disais tout à
l'heure aussi je crois vraiment que le
succès de ma prime rénove et de France
rénov repose sur un engagement partagé
aujourd'hui tous les Français ne sont
pas complètement égaux devant la
rénovation parce que les collectivités
locales n'ont pas le même engagement
d'une région à une autre d'un
département à l'autre d'une
intercommunalité à un autre on part pas
du même point et les aides de l'État
viennent s'additionner aux aides des
collectivités territoriales dans ce
sujet là et donc plus les collectivités
territoriales ont fait des efforts au
préalable plus nos concitoyens auront un
reste à charge le plus bas le plus bas
possible
oui mais il y en a il y en a déjà qui
qui sont engagés sur ces sujets là et
qui ne font et qu'ils font plutôt bien
en tout cas l'État lui continuera son
effort
deuxième vie
j'ai essayé de tout noter un ami
stratisation moi comme vous je crois au
dispositif seconde vie je pense que
c'est un dispositif qui qui sera présent
et on en a déjà beaucoup échangé dans le
pacte de confiance avec avec le monde
HLM
et et devrait permettre aux bailleurs
alors c'est pas des chiffres qui sont
tout de suite colossaux
on parlait entre 5 et 10 000 logements
de mémoire qui pourraient rentrer je me
tourne vers françois Adam
merci qui pourrait rentrer mais mais
c'est et puis ça fait le lien avec la
question de Monsieur ça ça recharge
l'exonération de TFPB ça
redonne une habilitation et un agrément
pardon au logement social et cette
rénovation extrêmement profonde qui est
aussi une réponse aux questions d'usage
et à d'autres questions c'est à dire
faire avec le déjà là me paraît
extrêmement vertueux et je souhaite
qu'on accompagne ce dispositif pour ce
qui est de la TFPB je comme ça je fais
le lien j'essaye d'être pas trop bête
dans mes réponses et assez liées les
bilans sont insuffisants
oui vous avez raison et extrêmement
inégaux d'ailleurs à l'autre d'un
territoire à l'autre moi je me rappelle
comme président de la rue avoir fait un
centre de visites en outre-mer où je
trouvais que l'utilisation on critique
souvent les bailleurs en outre-mer mais
l'utilisation de l'exonération de TFPB
que j'ai pu voir notamment à la réunion
était extrêmement dynamique
et vertueuse et pour et à d'autres
endroits sur
en hexagone je pense qu'on peut se poser
la question et d'ailleurs ça fait aussi
le lien avec la question de tout à
l'heure le NPV regardait aussi
l'utilisation de la TFPB dans ces dans
ces indicateurs à juste titre et donc
c'est c'est vraiment extrêmement
important que que cette exonération
imperdure de qu'elle soit utilisée en
surentretien en présence de gardien en
action sur le territoire et des actions
différentes si je prends l'exemple de
Clichy les bailleurs participent à ce
qu'on appelle de la prévention des des
des
patrouilles des médiateurs etc de nuit
mais participent aussi à des actions
pendant l'été etc donc je pense aussi
que sur ce sujet encore dans une
relation entre les bailleurs et les
collectivités locales et les maires
souvent
il est important de veiller à la bonne
utilisation de la TFPB
vous dire qu'on n'est pas sur un stop
and go je l'espère je ne sais pas du
prévoir de mon de ma durée de vie mais
en tout cas de mes de mon engagement et
de ma mobilisation je peux vous en
assurer et c'est l'objet de CNR qui
serait fin novembre de définir un cadre
une union sacrée autour du logement j'ai
demandé j'ai demandé à
Véronique bédag et à christophe Robert
d'être à mes côtés l'écho animateur
copporteurs de de de
ce CNR et il me survivrons ça c'est sûr
et donc je pense que c'est important que
que le Conseil national de la
refondation celui du logement et et
porte les les racines de ce que je
souhaite construire parce que
aujourd'hui on le sait le logement il y
a pas d'un côté les bailleurs sociaux
d'un autre côté les promoteurs d'un
troisième côté des élus etc tout le
monde est dans le dans le même bateau si
j'ose dire et c'est ça qu'il faut
construire et et la construction aussi
du pacte de confiance avec le monde HLM
et de la convention quinquennale doit
aussi participer à cette vision de ce
que peut-être le logement et et j'ai
le pacte de confiance c'est aussi bien
évidemment la mise en place d'une
conférence des des financeurs dans
lequel
la question de qui fait quoi qui met
quoi sera évidemment à l'ordre du jour
et aucun sujet
ni actuel ni passé ne seront de seront
tabou pour ma part avec une priorité en
tout cas pour la l'action de l'État y
compris dans le logement social c'est
celle de la rénovation et d'accompagner
les bailleurs dans la dans la rénovation
mais ils ont besoin qu'on leur donne
des moyens et qu'on les aide à à refaire
leur fonds propres qui aujourd'hui ne
leur permet pas forcément de d'être
aussi ambitieux qu'il le souhaiteraient
les touristiques
comment vous dire
ma volonté est telle qu'on trouvera le
vecteur législatif pour
pas faire que ce petit trou dans la
raquette permette à certains de s'y
infiltrer je pense que c'est extrêmement
important on a besoin de logement et de
logements classiques même si évidemment
la France est un beau pays touristique
et il est important que que l'offre
d'accueil reste présente là non plus je
suis pas dans une vision punitive mais
on le sait en zone touristique en zone
frontalière en zone de montagne on
commence à avoir de plus en plus de
difficultés à alloger ceux qui habitent
là et les enfants de ceux qui habitent
là et donc il faut trouver d'abord des
des moyens fiscaux pour faire que le
meublé touristique ne soit pas trop
incitatif et puis que le on n'y est pas
une un petit trou de souris dans lequel
des
des gens qui seraient pu digne à la
location classique deviennent d'un seul
coup sur un site que je ne citerai pas
très joli avec des petits rideaux
fenêtres et des rubans pour donner envie
de venir y passer un week-end
je bois un peu d'eau
oui ça parle bouclier tarifaire alors
vraiment la volonté de la première
ministre c'est de
ne rien oublier
en termes de bouclier tarifaire
le le la chose la plus difficile c'est
pas ce que ce que vous soulignez c'était
le chauffage électrique collectif qui
lui était
complètement en dehors des radars au
début et l'autre chose qui était en
dehors des radars c'est les parties
communes
du logement social dans lequel il y a
une vraie difficulté et les boucliers
n'étaient pas
présent
c'est même pas suffisamment mais pas
présent du tout donc on a je crois
trouver les voies et les moyens pour
régler ses problèmes qui qui concerne un
nombre de copropriétés assez importante
mais globalement tous les chauffages
collectifs au gaz et à l'électricité
auront un bouclier tarifaire jusqu'à la
fin
de cette année et les textes de ces
différents boucliers de chauffage
collectif
les sorties de ces textes sont
imminentes
le
donc il y avait le il y avait le gars
alors ce qui est vrai
oui oui ce qui est vrai c'est que malgré
le bouclier un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens vont voir une augmentation
importante parfois puisque un certain
nombre de bailleurs a juste titre
notamment les plus gros avec négocié des
tarifs de gaz extrêmement bas
y compris à des fournisseurs assez
exotiques voire russe et donc quand on
va pas reprocher au bailleur d'avoir
fait de bonnes négociations mais quand
on payait 20 euros du mégawattheure
dans des tarifs
hors réglementation ou concurrentielle
quand le bouclier il est à 65
les personnes vont avoir une
augmentation parfois de de x 3 mais s'il
n'y avait pas le bouclier ça serait x 5
x 6 x 10 qui comme on peut le voir au
Royaume-Uni par exemple donc malgré le
bouclier et vous devez le savoir quand
vous retournez dans vos départements et
que vous êtes alerté et bien ensemble de
Français qui vont voir néanmoins une
augmentation importante et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut y être attentif attentif pour
les plus fragiles attentifs à la santé
des copropriétés parce que parce que
l'appel de charge risque d'être plus
cher et puis il y a le sujet des copros
ou des bailleurs
dont les abonnements arrivent à échéance
et aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
fournisseurs proposent des prix qui sont
inacceptables et sur lequel il faut
qu'on continue
à être extrêmement attentif donc je peux
résumer
on essaye de boucher tous les trous dans
la raquette je crois qu'on en a pas
oublié
et ensuite pour chaque trou trouver le
texte qui va bien et une mise en œuvre
la plus rapide et la plus efficace
possible je ne dis pas des difficultés
mais je peux vous assurer que que la
première ministre yait extrêmement
attentif et à chaque fois que un
auditeur parle de ces sujets là à la
radio ou ailleurs elle ne manque pas de
nous dire mais comment ça se fait que ce
problème là n'est pas encore réglé et
elle a raison
j'espère ne pas être trop long tout va
bien bon
d'accord
je ne sais plus ce que j'ai appris à oui
quand même
la rue
vous vous doutez bien mon attachement à
ses programmes je lui dis tout à l'heure
12 milliards pour la Russe cette année
vous avez raison l'inscription
budgétaire de la participation de l'État
est à 15 millions d'euros vous le savez
aussi même si
400 projets 450 projets sur les 453 je
crois ont été validés passés en comité
d'engagement que ça soit sur les
programmes nationaux ou les programmes
régionaux donc on peut dire que
c'est quasi parfait et il reste des
morceaux c'est pas parce que des
programmes n'ont pas ils n'en reste
trois dans deux à Marseille mais il y a
aussi des morceaux de Marseille qui ont
qui ont déjà été validés puis un autre
en outre-mer donc ça marche mais vous
savez comment fonctionne la rue il y a
un pic qui est loin d'être pour l'année
2023 donc pour pour ce qui est de la
participation de l'État et des
différents partenaires Action Logement
et l'Union Sociale de l'habitat
l'argent aujourd'hui la trésorerie de la
rue permet très largement d'absorber etc
moi je crois en la parole de l'État
enfin et donc l'engagement l'engagement
qui est celui du gouvernement
d'accompagner leur rue à après de après
de deux milliards infinés doit être tenu
sinon on ne pourra pas on ne pourra pas
aller jusqu'au bout des programmes et
pour moi l'état l'État sera au
rendez-vous mais il faudra parce que le
pic il est prévu de mémoire du président
de la rue en 2025 26 26 plutôt
maintenant contenu des retards pris à
cause du covid et il faudra que dès
l'année prochaine on commence à mettre
plus plus d'argent sur les adultes
relais
le nombre de postes ouverts et vraiment
autour de 6500 après il y a un certain
nombre de difficultés
liée au turnover etc et effectivement
vous avez raison on est plutôt toujours
sur 5000 que sur les 6500 j'en parlais
il y a pas longtemps avec la pédèque de
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est pas un problème
d'argent c'est pas un problème de poste
ouvert c'est un problème de temps de
recrutement alors oui vous avez raison
il y a peut-être un sujet autour de
l'attractivité de ces postes notamment
dans une période où le plein emploi est
quand même plus présent que que cadeau à
d'autres moments donc ça fait partie des
sujets qui doivent être sur la table à
travers ses emplois aidés mais ce sont
des postes extrêmement importants
notamment dans le monde associatif ou
les adultes relais je joue un rôle
important on PV j'en ai parlé vous avez
raison j'ai fait une proposition pour
une nouvelle directrice directrice
présidente pardon de l'ompv parce qu'on
peut pas rester dans cette situation à
mon je pourrais dire qu'elle est
inacceptable la politique de la ville
elle se fait pas au doigt mouillé elle a
besoin d'être évaluée elle a besoin
d'être évaluée scientifiquement moi je
souhaite au-delà de l'anpv
m'entourer d'un conseil scientifique
pour pouvoir partager un certain nombre
de choses je trouve qu'il y a pas assez
de contrats chiffres dans le dans le
monde de la politique de la ville il y a
plein de doctorants qui pourraient venir
accompagner les questions de la
politique de la ville et donc voilà moi
je partage complètement avec vous il
faut recréer du lien avec la recherche
et et
se redoter et la NCT la même analyse je
dis pas qu'il faut revenir il y a eu des
moments où la MPV était très doté
la fusion avec la NCT un peu modifié les
choses mais mais on y reviendra
quartier 2030 politique de la ville
l'année qui vient est une une année
extrêmement importante celle où on va
réfléchir à la refonte des contrats de
ville je souhaite vraiment que que cette
démarche soit une démarche très
participative contributive que les
habitants y trouvent toute leur place
que que les associations petites et
grandes moi je pense que la politique de
la ville pour tout un tas de raisons eu
trop tendance depuis quelques années à
oublier les petites associations les
petits projets il faut se redonner les
moyens d'accompagner des projets locaux
il faut réinventer la participation des
habitants je veux pas
dire qu'il faut arrêter les conseils
citoyens c'est pas mon propos mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi donner la
possibilité là où ça ne marche pas parce
que c'est c'est difficile de faire vivre
un conseil citoyen sur la durée on est
dans la dans des formes de délégation de
pouvoir le
citoyens même celui qui est tiré au sort
perd une partie de sa crédibilité parce
que il retrouve dans un il se retrouve
dans un système un peu un peu régi par
le maire ou pas donc moi je suis plus
sur des formes informelles type de table
de quartier la NCT accompagne déjà les
tables de quartier je pense que les
accompagnera plus et mieux et en tout
cas on veut une démarche très très
ascendante avec des débats dans chaque
quartier en politique de la ville et
pour revenir à la question du zonage
vous avez raison
pour éviter de se fâcher avec trop de
monde je pense en 2014 on a inventé les
quartiers de veille de la politique de
la ville donc il y a eu probablement une
veille mais c'est des quartiers dans
lequel on ne mettait plus d'argent du
tout moi je crois
je crois qu'il y a besoin d'une
cartographie parce que
les critères du carroyage tel qu'ils ont
été utilisés en 2014 peuvent rester
pertinents même s'il faut en rajouter
d'autres
accès aux soins enfin etc je pense qu'on
peut encore améliorer les choses mais je
sais aussi qu'il
y a toujours des effets de bord des
effets de trottoir des bouts de quartier
oubliés dans lequel un quartier peut
plonger très vite et donc moi je
souhaite au-delà de du travail qu'on a
demandé à l'INSEE de nous dire bah voilà
quel serait la politique de l'écartier
en politique de la ville si on prenait
exactement la même règle qu'en 2014 et
bien on est un travail avec avec les
préfets les élus locaux le transfert de
la compétence aux intercommunalités doit
aussi nous permettre de de mieux
travailler cette cette cartographie au
plus près des besoins je dis pas que ça
sera avec plus d'argent
ce serait extrêmement tir aujourd'hui
mais mais en tout cas avec la
possibilité d'utiliser l'argent de la
politique de la ville là où c'est
nécessaire dans des quartiers
où les indicateurs même si on n'est pas
dans le carreau exactement au sens de
l'Insee où on estimera que c'est
nécessaire
oui très bien tous les sujets non pour
ce qui est des questions de Monsieur
blanche je pense avoir répondu sauf sur
Lausanne
et je vais je vais dire que
effectivement le
zan et d'abord une un objectif de long
terme
ensuite
ça vous avait rappelé le travail de
Christophe Béchu sur ce sujet-là et
effectivement il a pris cette question à
bras le corps il a annoncé avec la
première ministre qu'il reprenait les
échanges et le dialogue avec les
collectivités locales sur ce que tu es
peut-être une politique de la zéro
artificialisation nette moi je
je crois
je crois enfin en tout cas c'est une
intuition parce que c'est difficile de
se projeter qu'il faut comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure faire avec le déjà là le
plus souvent possible là où c'est
possible mais évidemment les questions
se posent différemment
dans un urbanisme dense ou ou dans des
urbanismes beaucoup plus détendu bon
donc je pense que le l'objectif du
gouvernement a juste titre et de
regarder ce sujet là
en dialogue avec avec les élus avec les
associations
bien évidemment pour pouvoir continuer à
à faire la ville à faire du logement
j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
construire plus pour le G+
on a besoin de construire du logement on
a besoin de faire la ville on a besoin
de créer de l'attractivité
à nos villes mais il y a aussi un
certain nombre de cas où ou
l'imperméabilisation a été par le passé
quelque chose une forme de facilité
aujourd'hui on n'a pas on a pu l'urgence
thématique est en présence on a pu cette
possibilité là de d'être dans la
facilité mais il faut il faut être
respectueux de
nos espaces
vers de nos espaces de nature de nos
espaces de nature en ville il faut aussi
redonner et le fond vert est fait pour
ça de la nature en ville la première
ministre a annoncé la notion de France
nation verte et la raison d'être dans
cette objective de valeur donc moi juste
renvoyer sur le débat et le dialogue que
le ministre souhaite auquel bien
évidemment dans les parcs qui sont la
même j'essaierai de m'associer
beaucoup monsieur le ministre qui me
soit permis de faire un vœu en cet
instant que le dialogue sur le zan que
vous appelez de vos vœux entre l'État et
les collectivités territoriales soient
plus écoutant que le dialogue que nous
avons combattu sur le SRU jusqu'à
présent voilà alors Florence blackrix
compta ensuite Evelyne Renault
garabédian
Florence Kim merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre
l'accès au logement pour les locataires
aujourd'hui et souvent limité par la
nécessité d'obtenir des cautions la
garantie visale est essentielle pour
aider les jeunes les salariés les plus
modestes à trouver un logement mais
cette garantie exclue les apprentis qui
n'ont pas encore 18 ans de même que les
étudiants qui n'ont pas encore 18 ans et
j'ai eu de nombreux cas de jeunes de fin
d'année qui ne pouvaient pas avoir accès
à la garantie visale donc pensez-vous
qu'il est possible de remédier à cette
difficulté et par ailleurs qu'en est-il
de l'engagement du président de la
République d'aller vers un dispositif de
caution élargie pour mieux lutter contre
les discriminations dans l'accès au
logement
deuxième point vous avez souligné la
nécessité de porter un effort sans
précédent dans le domaine de la
rénovation thermique d'être à
l'avant-garde éclairé de la transition
écologique vous avez évoqué les moyens
mis en place mais j'aimerais vous
entendre sur la structuration de la
filière parce qu'il faut que la filière
est capacité à y répondre à faire des
rénovations de qualité à ce qu'on est
suffisamment d'entreprises pour y
répondre et que les acteurs soient
convenablement formés donc elle est le
plan que vous avez prévu d'initier en la
matière et
troisième élément vous avez indiqué
qu'il fallait construire plus pour loger
plus et pour se faire il faut à mon avis
construire à prix abordable et dans de
nombreuses régions dont la mienne les
prix deviennent de plus en plus élevés
dans le département de l'Ain aux
frontières entre la métropole de Lyon et
Genève et on a un prix du foncier et de
l'immobilier qui devient vraiment très
élevé aujourd'hui les jeunes ne peuvent
plus acheter un terrain ne peuvent plus
acheter un logement donc est-ce que vous
envisagez des régulations pour justement
limiter cette hausse du foncier
permettent à tous de se loger et donc
c'est bien la propriété merci beaucoup
Evelyne Renaud gardabédian puis Sylviane
Noël merci ma présidente monsieur le
ministre je voudrais vous poser une
question générale sur les statut des
logements des non-résidents
les Français qui sont établis hors de
France ont souvent un bien en France qui
est considéré comme étant une résidence
secondaire
à ce titre ils ne peuvent bénéficier des
différentes exonérations des abattements
des déductions ou des crédits d'impôts
qui sont accordés au contraire biable
qui ont leur résidence fiscale en France
ils sont de plus redevables de surtaxe
ceci rend toute possession d'un actif
immobilier des Français qui vivent à
l'étranger particulièrement difficiles
et particulièrement onéreuse alors
qu'ils en ont vraiment besoin pour
rentrer en France ou bien pour le
illoger leurs enfants ou bien leur
famille le président de la République
s'est engagé au cours de la dernière
campagne présidentielle a étudié la
possibilité de la création d'une
résidence de repli qui serait
assimilable à une résidence principale
dans le but de ne pas pénaliser les
Français qui vivent à l'étranger et qui
sont dans une situation très
particulière je n'ai pas trouvé dans le
PLF 2023 quelle mesure il peut y avoir
en ce sens je voulais savoir si vous
avez envisagé
des aménagements pour ces non résidents
merci de votre réponse merci beaucoup
Evelyne Silviane Noël qui juste à côté
et ensuite Daniel salmon merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
souhaite vous interroger sur trois
points en faisant l'interprète de
nombreuses élus locaux premier sujet
vous évoquez tout à l'heure les
territoires touristiques notamment de
montagne confrontés à une très forte
prolifération des résidences
touristiques qui pose sérieuse
difficulté à l'habitat permanent c'est
le cas pour mon département de la
Haute-Savoie ou dans certaines communes
on peut compter jusqu'à 80% de résidence
secondaire et avec une charte et du
foncier qui devient rédhibitoire pour
l'habitat permanent avec tout ce que
cela comporte en termes de vitalité pour
ces territoires les élus sont démunies
face à ces phénomènes et ce n'est
malheureusement pas avec une sur taxe
d'habitation qu'on parviendra à freiner
ce phénomène donc pas question est
simple envisagez-vous de donner aux
maires des dispositifs plus coercitifs
pour limiter la prolifération de ces
résidences secondaires deuxième sujet
vous parliez tout à l'heure du parcours
résidentiel qui est un enjeu majeur et
je vous rejoins là-dessus mais force
cette constater que les collectivités
les bailleurs sociaux sont assez démunis
pour permettre de faire respecter
l'éligibilité au logement social dans le
temps
l'exemple typique d'une personne qui au
début de sa vie peut avoir droit à un
logement social puis il va trouver un
emploi en Suisse par exemple très bien
payé on lui appliquera une surtaxe sur
son loyer qui sera de toute façon
complètement dérisoire par rapport au
prix du logement dans le privé et donc
elle pourra rester cette personne dans
ce logement autant qu'elle le voudra
sans qu'on puisse y faire quoi que ce
soit et là je pense que il y a quand
même un sujet dans mon département
notamment on voit que les élus
construisent de plus en plus on a une
population permanente qui a 70% éligible
au logement social et on se rend compte
que un bon nombre de de résidents sont
sont voilà bénéficie de ces logements
sociaux alors qu'ils ne le devraient pas
donc est-ce que là aussi vous envisagez
une évolution réglementaire merci
beaucoup Daniel salmon suite Daniel
grenier
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
vous savez 80% de la ville de qui sera
là en 2050 est déjà construite donc
effectivement je vous apprends rien
c'est la rénovation qui doit et la
réalisat réhabilitation qui doivent
jouer à plein
je voudrais simplement avoir des
précisions ou des explications vous
savez annoncé 160 000 rénovations
globales
les chiffres de 2500 ne sortent pas de
n'importe où ça sort de la Cour des
comptes donc la Cour des comptes estime
qu'il y a que ça 2500 passwords
thermiques qui sont vraiment sortis de
cet état et donc qui ne sont plus ni
dans les classes EF nig lorsque vous
parlez de 30% de gains d'énergie sur les
160000 160
000 rénovations globales ça veut dire
que si on était à 400 kWh par mètre
carré par an on est passé à 280 donc on
est passé de fa2g
à eux ou de que je dise pas de bêtises
de FAE
c'est complètement insuffisant on le
sait très bien que lorsqu'il y a des
rénovations qui sont comme ça
insuffisantes on va mettre 5 ans on fait
un petit geste et puis 5 ans après on va
en faire un autre et tous les
professionnels nous disent que on n'est
pas là dans une démarche qui va apporter
vraiment une rénovation qui nous sort
des passoires et qui va vers les classes
A et B donc que ce que vous envisagez
vraiment pour booster cette prime rénove
qui de la vie générale n'apporte pas les
fruits les fruits attendus il y avait un
rapport d'Olivier sechel qui était qui
avait quand même de nombreux éléments
j'ai l'impression que c'est un rapport
lui aussi qui comme beaucoup de rapport
reste un petit peu à dormir et pourtant
il y avait c'était une boîte à outils
qui me semblait très très intéressante
pensez-vous vous y intéressez un peu
plus avec cette question des tiers
financeurs qui me semblent des questions
essentielles parce à la fois il faut
trouver le financement et je reprendrai
la question de ma collègue
Florence Béatrice compta la
structuration de la de la filière
comment l'envisagez-vous parce que
effectivement on va être devant un mur
effectivement je m'arrête là mais à ce
rythme là c'est 2500 ans qui nous faut
pour dire à vous des
passoires thermiques je pense que ça va
être un peu long
merci beaucoup quand on dit que la
politique du logement et de long terme
voilà Daniel grenier ensuite Rémi Cardon
oui merci Madame présente monsieur le
ministre je vais continuer sur ma prime
rénov sur trois aspects premier aspect
on a besoin de stabilité de visibilité
et il y a aussi demandé quelque part une
trajectoire c'est à dire sur une
lisibilité sur plusieurs années donc
quel est votre point de vue sur cet
aspect des choses je reviendrai aussi
sur ce qu'a dit notre rapporteur
Dominique expositionne sur la
copropriété je crois qu'on est largement
en dessous de nos espérances et qui a
une nécessité effectivement d'être plus
offensif parce que sur les logements
passoires ils sont significatifs au
niveau de la copro une question moyen
budgétaire de Lana au niveau de
l'instruction deuxième question les
travaux qu'on avait fait au niveau de la
commission économique du Sénat sur la
RER avait démontré une trajectoire avec
un accroissement des coûts aujourd'hui
sont vérifiés voir ils sont amplifiés
avec l'inflation et
les taux d'intérêt donc là aussi il y a
une question donc j'ai bien entendu
votre propos et je terminerai par ça en
disant que vous allez faire attention
que des logements ne quittent pas le
chant du locatif pour rentrer dans le
champ touristique mais c'est pas ça la
question la vraie question comment
accompagnons-nous d'une manière efficace
les propriétaires que parce que pour
certains mettent des locataires ou
interdire de louer c'est peut-être une
belle idée mais encore faut-il que
ceux-ci et les capacités financières à
faire les travaux or on est confronté à
cela aujourd'hui merci beaucoup Daniel
Rémy Cardon Yves Boulou merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre en
matière de la Renault de rénovation
thermique nous avons pris l'habitude de
nous fixer des objectifs ambitieux
toutes les décennies sans jamais nous
donner les moyens de nous ambitions je
reprendrai un peu les éléments que mon
collègue Daniel salmon a pris
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
effectivement sur les 700000 subventions
de ma prison attribué en 2021 le nombre
de logements sortis du statut de
password thermique ne serait que de 2500
d'après la Cour des comptes sachez qu'à
ce rythme là c'est effectivement 2000
ans pour rénover les passeurs thermiques
alors je vais peut-être aller plus
pragmatique sur la question c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement France
rénove et les accompagnateurs rénov pour
moi ne permettront pas de combler les
lacunes la seule condition serait tout
simplement un déploiement massif et
rapide sur les territoires et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je veux poser une
question sur les guichets physiques
France rénov qui sont implantés de
manière en tout cas pour moi inégal sur
les territoires pour pour vous donner un
exemple trois dans la Somme 17 dans le
Nord et un seul guichet dans l'Aisne ma
question est la suivante comptez-vous
ouvrir de nouveaux guichets physiques
sur le sur le territoire le cas échéant
comment seront répartis les
accompagnateurs rénov ou tout simplement
comptez-vous les intégrer aussi aux
maisons françaises
oui madame la Présidente merci Monsieur
le Ministre moi je vais revenir aussi
sur ma prime rénov et je rejoins ce
qu'on dit mais certains de mes collègues
effectivement c'est le process et la
filière qui est importante de savoir le
process pour la mise en oeuvre parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de collectivités
effectivement qui se sont engagés dans
des OPH pour lequel ils se sont j'allais
dire affiliés avec des mandataires pour
pouvoir aider à la restructuration
rénovation des bâtiments non je vais
partir d'exemples précis aujourd'hui il
y a des difficultés avec les mandataires
parce qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
maître d'oeuvre et on a des difficultés
à obtenir les devis et surtout à
solliciter les entreprises en tout cas
c'est ce que l'on observe sur le
territoire au point que certains
dossiers qui étaient priori enfin qui
semblait être éligibles deviennent
maintenant à la des sous transformés en
aide à la rénovation du logement indigne
et très dégradé ce qui n'est plus tout à
fait la même chose pour pour ses
habitants ça c'est ma première question
donc quelle mesure vous prenez pour
faire en sorte que vous proposez est-ce
que c'est votre accompagnateur j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
de la compagnateur Renov est-ce que
c'est lui qui va être plutôt assistance
maîtrise ouvrages mais aussi avec des
capacités de maîtrise d'oeuvre pour
pouvoir en tout cas engager Davant plus
vite les travaux la deuxième c'est
effectivement dans le cas d'après rénov
il y a eu beaucoup de marchands de
sommeil aussi est-ce que le l'état
contrôle j'irai les entreprises qui
travaillent au titre de l'ANAH parce
qu'il y a eu énormément de difficultés
en ce domaine et troisième point mais là
c'est sur l'enrue vous avez bien dit
qu'il fallait faire la ville donner de
l'attractivité vous avez parlé de la
ville moi je parle du quartier pourquoi
ne prend-t-on pas en compte justement
les rénovations réhabilitations dans
l'intégration d'un quartier des écoles
primaires ou des collèges et vous avez
un cas particulier pour lequel je me
suis mobilisé c'est à Amiens et touvi
parce qu'aujourd'hui sortent les
critères IPS des collèges ou des écoles
et on voit bien que les quartiers les
plus difficiles n'ont pas forcément les
collèges les plus attractifs comment
faire est-ce qu'on ne peut pas intégrer
dans les rénovations en rue là une
participation des fonds en rue dans les
rénovations des collèges et des écoles
primaires et maternelles merci Laurent
Yves Boulou qui est juste à côté de lui
monsieur le ministre
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans un entretien accordé un
capital il y a quelques jours vous avez
indiqué
réfléchir au statut des bailleurs des
bailleurs privés
pouvez-vous nous en dire un peu plus
très bien merci de la rapidité
Yves Martin Berthet ensuite Viviane
voulait reposer une question merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ma question sera très simple et
très courte il semblerait que dans le
projet de loi pour 2023 l'éligibilité à
la TVA 5 5 pour les travaux induits lors
de travaux de rénovation énergétique ne
soit plus possible pouvez-vous nous dire
ce qu'il en est précisément car les
acteurs du bâtiment sont très inquiets
merci Martine Viviane et ensuite Amel
gaker en toute promis d'être courte
merci vous avez indiqué dans vos propos
que tout geste de rénovation était utile
mais moi j'ai été alerté récemment sur
le fait que les DPE et ma prime rénov
favorisaient maintenant l'installation
de nouveaux systèmes de chauffage au
détriment des autres postes de la
rénovation de la rénovation est-ce que
c'est une
réorientation de la politique de
rénovation des logements alors que le
rapport se préconisé des rénovations
performantes et globales
vos Viviane merci Amel gaker et nous
finirons par Jean-Marc Boyer si je
n'oubliais personne madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre j'aimerais revenir
en fait sur le volet politique de la
ville précisément sur un sujet essentiel
celui de l'éducation dans les quartiers
prioritaires et notamment l'avenir des
cités éducatives lancé en 2019 on en
dénombre 200 aujourd'hui l'objectif je
le rappelle rapidement et de renforcer
la prise en charge pédagogique éducative
des jeunes de 0 à 25 ans dans et autour
de l'école des premiers bilans ont été
dressés j'aimerais vous entendre sur
deux points précis le premier les 16 25
ans qui aujourd'hui sont très peu trop
peu ciblés dans le cadre de ces
dispositifs la plupart des actions
faites s'adresse aux trois saisons et
pourtant les questions de formation
d'insertion d'emploi sont essentiels
dans ces quartiers prioritaires aussi et
le deuxième point évoqué dans ces bilans
et la nécessité de clarifier davantage
le cadre les attentes et les priorités
nationales des cités éducatives même si
on le sait le propre même en fait de ces
dispositifs portent sur l'adaptation
territoriale il n'en reste pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui les acteurs locaux
soulèvent en tout cas ce manque
peut-être de visibilité à long terme de
ces dispositifs donc mes questions
portent sur ces deux points merci c'est
Amel Jean-Marc
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit à deux reprises
il faut construire plus pour loger plus
c'est bien ça et je reviens à la
question qui a déposée pour mon collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc sur le zan parce que
Lausanne c'est moins 50% 2031 et 0% en
2050 ça me paraît très contradictoire
est-ce qu'on ne va pas arriver aux
résultats de effectivement de construire
moins pour l'objet plus
très bien et puis moi j'aurai deux
remarques monsieur le ministre pour
conclure cette série de questions à vous
nous répondiez
la première c'est que vous nous avez
plusieurs fois parlé du CNR logement et
des travaux que vous allez mener moi je
voulais vous dire simplement que il y a
5 ans ici on a fait des États généraux
du logement avant la loi Elan et que je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'informations
dans ces états généraux dont vous
pourriez rapidement vous inspirer sans
refaire un tut tut de pouet pouet le
deuxième chose pardonnez-moi et la
deuxième chose ouais on aimerait bien on
aimerait bien gagner du temps et que les
grandes messes voilà soient utiles ce
que j'espère que dans cinq ans fera pas
un CNR ou un je sais pas un CN je sais
pas quoi voilà
la deuxième chose vous nous avez dit
convaincre les élus de la construction
vous avez utilisé plein de fois
cette expression qu'il faut convaincre
les élus de construire moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose que j'ai dit au
Premier ministre il y a 5 ans c'est
qu'en supprimant la taxe d'habitation en
gelant les compensations de la taxe
d'habitation à 2017 la construction de
logements n'est plus un sujet pour les
mères ils en veulent pas ils peuvent
plus utiliser et accueillir de nouvelles
populations car ils ne peuvent plus
construire des colles pour eux ils n'ont
plus de liens citoyens entre la commune
et les nouveaux habitants qui arrivent
c'est un sujet majeur de citoyenneté et
de moyens pour les élus de bien
accueillir les populations et je pense
que vous ne ferez pas l'économie de
quelque chose qui redonne de la
dynamique à aux ressources et qu'une
dynamique qui soit liée à la fois au
logement mais aussi au développement
économique il me semble que c'est un
sujet majeur
vous laisse la parole et vous avez 10
minutes donc
on va essayer de
alors sur je vais prendre des questions
alors si vous permettez sinon je vais
pas m'en sortir
sur visage pour moi il faut qu'on
regarde franchement
si c'est des apprentis comme moins de 18
ans il y a peut-être là aussi un sujet
mais mais le fait d'être apprenti
n'exclut pas d'avoir accès à la garantie
pardon c'est le fait d'être mineur donc
si c'est un cas qui qui
revient souvent il faut qu'on regarde le
sujet pour ce qui est de l'extension de
visa ça fait partie du programme du
président de la République il faut il
faut qu'on y travaille et d'ailleurs
dans le cadre de la convention
quinquennale et des réflexions qu'on
mène avec Action Logement
aujourd'hui la garantie visale a aussi
une vertu de par dans un certain nombre
de cas son exception qui donne
un certain nombre de futurs locataires
une espèce de bonus il faudrait pas que
l'extension de visale
fasse perdre à au plus modeste
et à ceux pendant le plus besoin une
capacité de rentrer dans le logement
donc il faut qu'on prépare cette
extension tout en préservant des
garde-fous qui fait que aujourd'hui
le fait d'avoir visale donne à des
personnes qui sont si on va comme ça se
présenter chez un propriétaire n'aurait
pas forcément beaucoup de chance de
trouver un logement mais grâce à visa
les le trouve si tout le monde a la même
le même état est-ce que est-ce que ça
aurait pas un effet pervers sur ceux qui
ont le plus besoin de se loger c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on travaille
mais bien évidemment la volonté du
Président de la République de mettre en
oeuvre son programme et et toujours
présente
ensuite les questions de rénovation
alors ça c'est revenu plusieurs fois
j'y reviendrai peut-être un peu plus
tard vous avez vous avez parlé du de
construire un prix abordable oui c'est
c'est une obligation je pense qu'il
y a d'abord des difficultés
structurelles et et
liée à l'actualité sur le coup des
matériaux etc mais la question du
foncier que vous avez abordé est une
question déterminante il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on étudie toutes les pistes
d'abord celle des fonciers publics
ceux de l'état
de la SNCF ou que sais-je qu'on continue
à travailler sur le bail réel solidaire
et et les questions les questions de
créer des offices fonciers solidaires
les solfabilisés et accompagnés parce
que ça ça marche ça marche dans beaucoup
de régions et de plus en plus donc je
pense que c'est un bon outil qu'il faut
continuer à développer et accompagner il
y a un sujet
en tout cas dans mes réflexions mais sur
lesquelles je veux pas prendre
d'engagement aujourd'hui la fiscalité
du foncier et d'une certaine manière
inversée plus on garde un foncier moi on
paye d'impôts et donc c'est pas
forcément très vertueux dans une volonté
de de produire
donc voilà c'est fait partie des sujets
qui sont qui sont les miens sur lequel
je pars en capacité aujourd'hui de vous
donner une réponse mais en tout cas qui
sont dans nos dans nos radars
pour la question de Madame et la
résidence de repli je vais pas vous
mentir c'est un sujet qui à ma
connaissance je ne sais pas si on a
travaillé déjà sur sur ce sujet
et c'est peut-être mal pour un ministre
mais je le découvre un peu aujourd'hui
donc on va on va on va le regarder avec
attention enfin je vois bien la question
évidemment c'est tout sauf une résidence
secondaire vous avez raison
cette résidence lorsqu'on va travailler
à l'étranger pour un certain nombre
d'années on va pas vendre son logement
ou donc voilà je prends le la question
et si vous permettez on reviendra vers
vous et on vous fera une réponse écrite
donc les résidences les résidences
secondaires d'abord vous le savez il y a
une une extension du nombre de villes
dans lequel on offre la possibilité aux
maires d'augmenter la taxe sur la
résidence secondaire
il y avait 400 communes
4000 auprès
du nombre de villes dans lequel les
maires pourront prendre des dispositions
mais je pense que sur ce sujet là c'est
vraiment bien de donner le pouvoir au
maire pour qu'il puisse décider si il
augmente la taxe sur les résidences
secondaires ou si ils estiment que c'est
aussi important pour le communes de
garder l'idée c'est pas de d'empêcher la
résidence secondaire et d'être punitif
au contraire ça peut aussi être une
plus-value pour pour une ville d'avoir
pendant des périodes de l'année des pics
de population le la question de de
perdre son droit au logement social et
l'unification du surloyé c'est une
question qui est importante qui est
difficile vous savez qu'il y a des
dérogations a déjà dans les quartiers en
rue
le soleil le surloyé ne s'applique pas
puisque ça peut permettre pendant un
temps
de contribuer à la mixité mais mais
c'est évidemment un sujet sur lequel il
faut qu'on qu'on regarde pour des cas
très particuliers de gens qui
travaillent à l'étranger je sais pas
s'il y a déjà eu des des
actions de mise en œuvre pour des cas
particuliers il me semble que on a 2 ans
pour quitter le domicile de mémoire
lorsqu'on dépasse de
c'est ça ouais c'est ça si on dépasse
150 % du plafond normalement il y a une
obligation à quitter le le et il doit y
avoir l'enquête de surveiller enfin
quand on est locataires on reçoit tous
les ans ou tous les deux ans je crois
une enquête sur le niveau de ressources
et c'est au bailleur aussi de mettre
pardon
je pense que je pense qu'il faut un
travail sur l'automne l'automatisation
du surloyé et de le respect de la règle
bien sûr bien sûr vous avez raison
alors sur sur la structuration de la
filière
je ne sais plus qui a posé les questions
bon
c'est un travail extrêmement important
alors qui est mené par sur plusieurs
fronts et par plusieurs ministres vous
savez que Bruno Le Maire et ministère
d'économie des finances on aurait mis en
oeuvre les assises du bâtiment dans
lequel les questions de la structuration
de la filière ont été extrêmement abordé
il y a plusieurs sujets il y a la
qualification des entreprises et des
artisans dans leur capacité à réaliser
les travaux et à rendre l'entreprise
éligible aux primes puisque on peut pas
faire des travaux avec une entreprise
qui n'a pas toutes les qualifications
donc c'est un travail qui qui est mené
les fédérations que j'ai rencontrées la
Fédération française du bâtiment la
CAPEB sont extrêmement mob utiliser sur
ces sujets là et travaille à la
formation des apprentis à la création
d'un certain nombre de cap maison si
j'ose dire pour avoir les bras pour
mener les chantiers la CAPEB notamment à
demander lors des assises à juste titre
qu'on prolonge l'expérimentation pour
obtenir la qualification RGE au chantier
et effectivement je pense qu'ils ont
raison si une entreprise a fait
plusieurs chantiers et
à réussir la rénovation je crois qu'au
bout de trois chantiers qu'ils
obtiennent la qualification s'il en fait
trois fois il y a par exemple qui ne
réussissent pas à le faire une quatrième
fois et simplifier l'obtention des
l'obtention des qualifications est
extrêmement importante il faut pas nier
sur ce sujet là le rôle des
collectivités locales notamment des
régions qui sont les acteurs de la
formation et qui doivent accompagner la
structuration donc les axes de travail
je l'ai dit la formation l'attractivité
des métier qui sont présents moi j'étais
au salon bâtiment il y a quelques
semaines et
la TFPB la TFT
la Fédération française du bâtiment
allez FFB et très active dans la dans la
valorisation et la tractivité de ces
métiers à travers des outils numériques
notamment de de pour accueillir le plus
de jeunes moi moi je suis très favorable
à l'Allée Verte je pense que il est
important que que les entreprises du
bâtiment
aillent dans les dans les quartiers
présentent leur métier que les que les
lycées des métiers participent aussi à
la au recrutement et à allergissement de
ce métier et puis bien évidemment pour
que ça marche il faut lutter contre les
fraudes et donc avoir des entreprises de
qualité et puis c'est un cercle vertueux
j'entends ce que vous avez dit sur le
temps sur les insuffisances etc mais
plus plus l'éco-geste plus la rénovation
thermique euh sera euh dans les mœurs et
c'est déjà le cas je crois il y a
vraiment eu un un saut dans dans les
esprits de nos concitoyens plus le
besoin sera présent plus la filière
s'alimentera et se développera je pense
que il y a il faut être dans cette dans
cette dynamique vertueuse
sur le statut du bailleur privé
je vais pas vous donner le le résultat
de de nos de nos réflexions et des
sujets qui sont encore sur la table
il y a vraiment un
peu comme dirait le président de la
République il y a pas de ministre
magique je pense que c'est fait partie
des sujets qui vont qui vont être portés
par un certain nombre de de nos de nos
partenaires et d'ailleurs pour
je vu le nombre de consultations que je
fais il y a dans la vision des uns et
des autres
de la FNAME des promoteurs tout le monde
parle d'un statut du bailleur privé mais
tout le monde n'a pas exactement la même
vision dans dans la tête donc moi ce que
ce que je pense c'est que d'abord ça
s'accompagne de l'avenir de la
défiscalisation la question du bailleur
privé est aussi une question qui est à
pourquoi on achète pour mettre en
location
quelle obligation on se donne en terme
social environnemental etc quels sont
les
comment on fait à travers ce statut pour
simplifier uniformiser les différents
régimes fiscaux et quels sont les
incitations que l'on met autour de ce
statut donc
produire là et acheter là où il y a le
plus besoin donc en zone tendue une
incitation liée à la rénovation
énergétique enfin le bailleur privé ne
peut pas être propriétaire d'une
passoire je pense que c'est extrêmement
important et puis le bailleur privé tel
que je l'entrevois propose des loyers à
prix abordable donc une fois qu'on a dit
ça il faut travailler à ce que sont les
incitations
les droits et les devoirs de ce bailleur
privé mais c'est un chantier que l'on va
mener avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
logement comme d'autres chantiers
j'ai sauté des questions je crois
vous en avez regroupé
il y en a tout un tas sur ma prime
rénove mais je vais répondre après
sur sur ma prime rénove je vais essayer
de de répondre à plusieurs questions
celle des celle des guichets je sais
plus qui m'a posé
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure la création de de France Renov
et pas partie de rien il y a un certain
nombre d'action qui était mené par Lana
et puis un certain nombre d'actions qui
étaient territorisés donc les
territoires qui étaient les plus
vertueux
sont ceux où effectivement aujourd'hui
les guichets physiques sont les plus
nombreux parce que il y avait une
dynamique propre aux territoires qui qui
avait mis en place une allée ou ou un
lieu d'accueil pour présenter les
différents projets et énergétiques donc
la création du guichet unique et le
numéro unique permet de de
d'essayer de
d'uniformiser
la proposition mais mais bien évidemment
il faut maintenant trouver des solutions
là où il y avait moins de
prise en compte de ces questions là dans
certains territoires et dans certains
départements aujourd'hui il y en a 475
espace d'information je lui mets note je
connais pas je connais pas ce chiffre
par cœur par contre ce que je sais c'est
qu'on a 4000
conseillers France rénov et notre
objectif c'est d'avoir à la fin de
l'année 2023 Camille 4000
accompagnateurs rénov
l'accueil physique il est nécessaire
vous avez raison très probablement mais
mais le premier accueil téléphonique à
travers le numéro unique doit permettre
aux gens qui appellent d'être adressés
vers l'accueil physique qui il est pas
forcément encore complètement répartis
de manière uniforme peut-être qu'il le
faudra les maisons français services
doivent jouer un rôle dans ces dans ces
dans ces dispositions
[Musique]
par rapport aux chiffres et au 160000
versus les les 2000
moi j'ai quand même
tendance à croire le travail que mène
Lana et et les chiffres qu'il me
redonnent sinon
donc 160 000 rénovations globales depuis
2020 d'après la NA c'est 40
ma prime rénov sérénité donc un
accompagnement des familles les plus
fragiles parents depuis 2020
et et c'est des gains énergétiques
d'environ une baisse de dépenses
énergétique de
50%. donc on a déjà fait du performant
il faut continuer à le faire j'entends
ce que vous dites sur la critique du
geste néanmoins
c'est des chiffres qui sont
non significatifs et les 2500
par rapport au 160 000 les 2500 c'est
ceux qui ont donné droit à bonus donc
qui ont fait encore plus que les 160 000
rénovations globales donc les deux
chiffres sont vrais le bonus c'est un
chiffre qui qui enfin
un niveau de réhabilitation encore
supérieur à la performance exigée je dis
pas que c'est parfait et franchement
c'est pas du tout mon propos depuis tout
à l'heure et surtout le chemin qui est
devant nous c'est celui de l'habitat
collectif aujourd'hui l'essentiel des
chantiers ont été portés dans de
l'habitat individuel donc ça représente
beaucoup de chantier mais mais le
l'enjeu majeur qui est le nôtre c'est
celui de lancer ma prime rénov enfin
lancée continuer à ma prime manœuvre
copropriété pour pour porter un certain
nombre de
projets en copropriété en sachant que
que toute la complexité que ça ça peut
représenter c'est pour ça qu'il faut
accompagner les conseils syndicaux et
les syndics les former
regarder aussi en l'occurrence les
qualifications parce que
l'accompagnateur Renov c'est une
question aussi qui a été posée doit
aider à trouver la MO mais a priori même
si un certain nombre d'architectes
s'intéressent et demandent à être agréé
accompagnateur rénov là cela auront les
compétences pour faire accompagner une
copropriété
jusqu'au bout quelqu'un a parlé tout à
l'heure des tiers financeurs oui vous
avez vous avez raison c'est c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut développer
la région Île-de-France ici en région
Île-de-France il y a
Île-de-France énergie que j'ai rencontré
ce matin qui mène ça mais aujourd'hui
leur moyen sont insuffisants pour
accompagner la totalité des chantiers
c'est pour ça aussi que je disais tout à
l'heure que c'est un c'est pas
l'état contre les collectivités locales
ou c'est c'est vraiment l'État avec les
collectivités locales pour pour avancer
sur sur ces chantiers de de rénovation
pour aller tout à la fois préserver la
massification qui a été les gens directs
et aller vers des performances plus
importantes et et la globalité mais on
ne pourra pas faire si les collectivités
ne sont pas à nos côtés
j'ai pas répondu aux questions de
Monsieur
sur la rue et tout ça c'était avant j'ai
noté j'ai noté donc la compagnateur j'ai
commencé à répondre sur amo pas Mo ça
dépendra
alors il y a aucun doute aujourd'hui la
rue permet de financer des équipements
publics et en particulier des écoles
comme président de la rue je n'ai cessé
de poser pardon je n'ai cessé de peser
des premières pierres d'école et et de
et maintenant dans l'inaugurer et c'est
d'ailleurs la preuve que les chantiers
avancent alors pour les collèges c'est
un peu différent parce que même si les
collectivités ont des difficultés
financières les départements ne sont pas
dans la même situation financière que
que
la plupart des collectivités locales à
ce stade la rue facile en rue veut faire
son travail c'est comme par exemple en
rue ne finance pas de piscine parce que
il y a l'Agence nationale de sport il y
a d'autres personnes qui peuvent le
faire donc la rue se concentre sur
l'accompagnement des collectivités
locales il est arrivé que la rue
intervienne sur des collèges mais plutôt
j'ai un exemple Mirail par exemple où il
y a un projet de fermeture de collège
pas marché de redistribution de la carte
scolaire et de modification de la carte
scolaire et ensuite sur le foncier du
collège on travaille avec avec la ville
pour créer
une zone d'activité notamment mais
l'enrue est très présente sur la
rénovation des écoles ce que je crois
c'est la question qu'on se pose tous
quand mes parents dans quelle école je
vais mettre mes enfants et est-ce
qu'elle va être belle donner la
condition de de la réussite et donc la
rue est très présente sur les
équipements publics les équipements
sportifs hors piscine parce que on peut
pas refaire la ville on s'intéressant
qu'à la question du logement bien
évidemment voilà
le statut du bailleur alors la TVA 5 5
pour moi il y a pas de changement sur
cette question là et alors là je lis ma
note il y a pas d'inquiétude parce que
c'est toujours couvert mais le code
général des impôts a évolué et c'est
plus la peine de l'inscrire dans dans
les textes telles que c'était le cas
avant je ne sais plus qui regarder je ne
sais pas qui a mais voilà voilà je ne
savais pas qui avait posé
cette cette question
alors sur
sur les cités éducatives d'abord le
on a annoncé le prolongement de trois
ans des cités éducatives elles devaient
s'arrêter et elle continue et moi j'y
suis extrêmement attaché je crois
vraiment à cette manière de travailler
en décloisonnant et en travaillant dans
le trium viral éducation nationale
collectivités locales
état comme dit Jean-Luc Borloo il faut
tout un village pour pour élever un
enfant et je pense qu'il a qu'il a
raison oui les cités éducatifs sont
plutôt centrées sur
la petite enfance la maternelle
l'école élémentaire le collège est un
peu le lycée notamment sur les questions
d'orientation
sur les plus âgés
on n'est pas au cœur des cités
éducatives c'est pas pour ça que la
politique de la ville et l'action de
l'État ne s'y intéresse pas
vous savez que que la première ministre
actuelle lorsqu'elle était ministre du
Travail à lancer le dispositif un jeune
une solution et je crois vraiment qui
qui joue son rôle
les tous les les chantiers les aides
qu'on a qu'on a amené auprès des
missions locales auprès
auprès de Pôle Emploi pour aller vers
les invisibles accompagner les jeunes
dans leur recherche d'emploi en
particulier ceux qui étaient le plus
éloignés sont dispositifs qui marchent
l'évolution de la garantie jeune en
contrat d'engagement jeune et est un
dispositif qui marche plutôt bien
j'étais plusieurs fois dans ma vie de
d'élus et de mère président de Mission
Locale je peux vous assurer que les
relations entre les jeunes et leur
mission locale et leur conseiller
mission locale ont été profondément
modifier depuis de nombreuses années la
mission locale a souvent été le très
mauvais objet lorsqu'on rencontrait des
jeunes dans nos quartiers aujourd'hui
leur relation sont très apaisées parce
que les missions locales apportent des
solutions inscrivent les jeunes dans le
dans des parcours de d'emploi en tout
cas de d'abord de formation plus
d'emplois néanmoins c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut ne pas le faire et les
contrats de ville de demain auront bien
évidemment
une prise en compte des jeunes de 16 à
25 ans mais pas forcément au sein des
cités éducatives même si
ce n'est pas interdit mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas le l'esprit complètement
de départ des cités en tout cas pour
pour les jeunes qui tend le qui tend le
lycée l'idée des cités tels qu'elles ont
été construites pardon
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais sur
la sur les plus âgés c'est notamment les
questions d'orientation après les cités
se sont en libres administration par les
collectivités locales bon moi je pense à
la mienne par exemple on a on a un
projet de de
Summer Camp si j'ose dire de préparation
au rentrée universitaire des jeunes de
Clichy-sous-Bois parce que on sait que
le passage d'un lycée dans lequel on est
très bien encadré notamment dans les
quartiers populaires où il y a une vraie
politique éducative
l'arrivée dans la vie universitaire et
difficile et il y a un nombre d'échecs
en première année de de fac extrêmement
importante donc on travaille à des
projets inscrits dans les situations
éducatives d'accompagnement des jeunes
lycéens devenant devenant étudiants rien
ne l'interdit à ce stade mais je pense
que tout ça doit aussi s'adosser au
travail que mène les
le zan je pense que j'ai déjà d'abord
c'est vraiment un chantier qui est en
cours je veux juste qu'on n'oublie pas
en permanence que le N2 est un net et
que là où on peut artificialiser pour
construire ça veut dire que à d'autres
endroits il faut redonner
de la
[Musique]
fin de la non perméabilité fin de la
perméabilité pardon donc c'est c'est
aussi rien ne s'oppose au contraire le
net doit s'appliquer donc on peut
construire un endroit et redonner de la
perméabilité ailleurs et c'est ce
chantier là qu'il faut mener sur la
définition et le dialogue tel qu'il a
été
défini ensuite et je terminerai en vous
pendant madame la Présidente non non
évidemment
les parlementaires comme ils le sont
dans le CNR du national de lancer à
Marcoussis resteront et seront invités
au CNR logement
les travaux déjà menés dans leur de vos
états généraux
on va les si ce n'est déjà fait mais je
ne doute pas que la DHP et l'ensemble de
mes collaborateurs les connaissent comme
bien évidemment on a lu avec attention
avant même d'être ministre pour ma part
le rapport de François
Rebsamen dans lequel un certain nombre
d'entre vous ont contribué comme j'ai lu
aussi le rapport Sichel sur les
questions de rénovation thermique et
donc n'hésitez pas à continuer à
alimenter moi j'étais
je suis aussi très attentif au travail
qui a été mené par un certain nombre de
sénatrices présentes ici sur le le des
contrats de ville et ça et ça inspire
nos réflexions sur la construction des
des nouveaux contrats de ville donc
voilà et puis et puis vous l'avez dit
convaincre les élus de te l'acte de
construire je le partage avec vous je
l'ai dit mais c'est pas pour les beaux
yeux du ministre bien évidemment ça
passe aussi par des incitations
[Musique]
j'apprécie pas forcément l'expression du
maire bâtisseur mais en tout cas les
maires qui construisent doivent
en voir un intérêt d'abord pour leur
population parce que moi je veux bien
qu'on compense que on n'a pas envie de
construire mais quand on est maire
[Musique]
99% de nos rendez-vous aujourd'hui c'est
pour demander un logement pour eux pour
soi pour ses enfants et c'est juste donc
on peut pas en même temps dire qu'on
veut pas construire et et
ou voir dans son à côté de sa petite son
petit appartement son appartement ou sa
maison de banlieue il refusait mais ça
veut dire oui comme on l'a fait dans le
cadre du plan de relance accompagner les
maires leur donner les moyens de
réaliser les écoles
accompagner le les nécessaires besoin en
équipement public lorsque la population
augmente mais je rappelle quand même
Homer que ne pas construire n'est pas
ne permet pas d'atteindre le le point de
neutralité quand on construit pas
mathématiquement sa population baisse et
un moment ça dégage baisse etc si on
veut avoir la neutralité de sa
population il faut construire parce que
sinon c'est automatique mathématique en
gardant le même nombre de logements sa
population baisse ça DGF baisse c'est
moyen baisse et donc
je pense que tout le monde a intérêt
pour loger et pour la dynamique de son
territoire de construire voilà vous avez
presque épuisé ma voix donc il est temps
je vous remercie merci beaucoup ce n'est
pas l'ancien maire que j'ai à ma droite
que je redirais que c'est pas tellement
de problèmes de l'investissement quoi
que ça va le devenir dans les c'est le
fonctionnement dans le temps voilà vous
savez très bien entretenir des écoles
des Atsems faire descendre de loisirs
des crèches c'est l'investissement mais
c'est surtout dans le temps et donc
comme les
les moyens financiers des communes
s'appauvrissent de façon spectaculaire
spectaculaire en 2022 et en 2023 c'est
Pierre puisque aujourd'hui
personne ne sait comment il va boucler
son budget le sujet est quand même un
sujet de la même si on a la queue devant
notre bureau pour faire pour trouver des
logements il y a un moment où on sait
pas faire non plus dans la quadrature du
cercle voilà donc il y a un vrai sujet
là de financement de la population
supplémentaire en attendant c'est un
sujet dont on aura l'occasion de
reparler et on aura un autre sujet qu'on
n'a pas du tout abordé je suis presque
presque frustré que vous partiez sur
collaborde mais je vous les laissais
partir quand même c'est le sujet des
attributions de logements sociaux c'est
un gros sujet ici c'est un gros sujet
dans les petites collectivités je suis
sûr que vous avez plein d'idées et donc
on vous fera revenir là-dessus à notre
jour voilà des parcs réservateurs et ma
vision de son évolution avec
l'attribution en flux voilà super merci
beaucoup